maximum je donne tout de suite la parole
à jean-marc jancovici qui se
présentaient qui nous dit en cinq
minutes
ce qu'il faut savoir de son point de vue
sur cette question quels outils quelles
outils pour quels objectifs
alors le haut conseil pour le climat est
un ensemble de treize personnes qui sont
en cdd
np alors cdd donc on est en contrat à
durée déterminée on est nommé pour un
mandat de cinq ans et cnp parce que
c'est non payés voilà alors c'est quoi
plus sérieusement cette affaire-là
c'est un organe un de plus direz-vous
qui a été créée en novembre dernier
placé auprès du premier ministre et qui
est chargé alors on a un mandat qui est
extrêmement vague de donner un avis sur
la trajectoire française en matière
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre donc
en gros on dit ce qu'on veut sur la
politique climat de la france
bon alors c'est en gros c'est exactement
ça notre mandat la limite de l'exercice
qui est le qui est le nôtre en fait est
une limite de moyens et de temps parce
que comme je le disais quand on est 13
on ne sait toujours pas qui de judas
donc quand on est 13
en fait on est descendu à 11 pour le
moment on va remonter à xiii et qu'on a
un jour par mois de présence de réunions
plus un jour par mois de lecture de
documents échanges de mails etc
c'est assez facile de comprendre qu' il
ya des choses qu'on peut faire et des
choses qu'on peut moins facilement faire
et donc en pratique on regarde surtout
des grandes orientations et des grandes
tendances
on va dire il ya une partie facile à une
partie plus difficile dans notre travail
la partie facile c'est voir qu'on n'est
pas dans les clous donc là c'est très
facile faut 15 secondes pour voir qu'on
n'est pas dans les clous
la partie beaucoup plus difficile c'est
est ce qu'on peut avoir un avis sur
lequel on est tous d'accord parce qu'une
des limites ou un des mandats plus
exactement qu'on s'est fixés c'est que
on écrivait que des choses sur
lesquelles on était tous d'accord parce
que sinon on n'était pas capable d'aller
défendre ailleurs il ya une limite
importante
là c'est donc de rentrer un tout petit
peu dans le dans le détail des choses on
a sorti un premier rapport en juin
dernier
alors dans ce rapport en gros il ya
trois mois important il ya un mot qui
s'appelle cohérence
il ya un mot qui s'appelle planification
et ya un mot qui s'appelle justice alors
je vais revenir sur ces trois mots très
rapidement le mot cohérence il est
essentiel parce que en fait le défis que
nous pose le changement climatique
c'est le défi de confronter nos rêves de
grandeur et d'infini à la limite
physique de ce monde
voilà c'est ça le problème du changement
climatique c'est qu'on avait des rêves
de grandeur et d'infini vous vous avez
tous entendu les discours sur la
croissance économique qui est censé
durer 2
perpétuel et c'est qu'on a tous des
rêves d'infini qu' on peut exercer
chacun une liberté croissante sans gêner
celle d'à côté ça ça marche bien dans un
monde en croissance ça marche pas dans
un monde sans croissance
donc on est à devoir confronter la
vision qu'on avait avant d'une espèce
d'expansion sans limite à la difficile
limites physiques du monde et notamment
la limite physique sur le système
climatique qui est qu' il ya une
certaine quantité de co2 qu'on peut
mettre dans l'atmosphère avant de
trouver l'expérience extrêmement
désagréable voilà c'est ça le c'est ça
la première chose est alors donc cette
ce nous tous cette nouvelle limite qu'on
a dans la façon de gérer nos petites
affaires devient contradictoire avec un
certain nombre d'autres directions qu'on
avait prises et aujourd'hui on a un
problème de mise en cohérence et cette
mise en cohérence en fait ne se fera pas
sans choix c'est-à-dire sans abandon
c'est le poète a dit choisir c'est
renoncer
donc il ya des choses auxquelles on va
devoir renoncer malheureusement c'est ça
la mise en cohérence est aujourd'hui une
des fortunes des recommandations fortes
de notre rapport c'est que on ne se
donne pas la peine de faire cette mise
en cohérence c'est à dire qu'on ne se
donne pas la peine de se demander à nous
mêmes au fond qu'est-ce qu'on préfère si
on peut pas tout avoir
c'est sale c'est ça le premier
enseignement de notre rapport
le deuxième enseignement s'appelle
planification parce que la raison pour
laquelle on a aujourd'hui une société
qui est basée sur ce qu'on appelle les
énergies fossiles c'est à dire le
charbon le pétrole et le gaz
même en france vous savez que même en
france l'essentiel de l'énergie qui
alimente nos machines
c'est des énergies fossiles 1 c'est pas
essentiellement de l'électricité c'est
essentiellement des énergies fossiles à
commencer par le carburant des voitures
que vous utilisez tous et des avions que
nos amis de la guyane ont sûrement pris
pour venir ici à moins qu'ils joignent
en kayak de mer
donc ce que vous avez aujourd'hui qui
fait fonctionner le monde sait les
énergies fossiles et donc se passer de
ces énergies fossiles c'est changer la
façon dont le monde est organisé et
changer les villes changer les modes de
transport changer les modes alimentaires
etc qui sont des votes culturel a en
france on adore bien manger pour bien
raison etc
c'est des choses qui sont très longues
ce très long et donc sa demande de la
planification exactement comme dans les
choses importantes de notre ville qui
sont longues
par exemple élever un enfant en général
on planifie pas mais on essaye de faire
les choses avec constance et avec
organisation est en fait la
planification c'est ça donc l'aide le
deuxième enseignement fort de notre
rapport c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on se donne pas les moyens d'avoir une
action qui est organisée de façon un peu
cohérente dans le temps et puis le
troisième mot c'est justice parce qu il
est bien évident qu'il ya un moyen très
simple par exemple de baisser les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
trois quarts s'est tué les trois quarts
des gens physiquement ça marche très
très bien
on peut pas considérer que ce soit une
solution très juste voilà donc le la
question de savoir qu'est ce qu'on peut
proposer qui sera considéré comme
sympathique c'est ça à fond la justice
c'est acceptable
et bien c'est le troisième enseignement
important du rapport s'est il faut
réfléchir à des mesures qui suscitent
quand même un minimum d'adhésion
ça veut dire en particulier un truc très
important c'est qu'elle doit être
comprise parce que c'est très compliqué
d'adhérer à un truc qu'on comprend pas
donc là il ya aussi un vrai sujet que
j'ai relevé dans les changes qui vient
de se presser des 2 me précédée là qui
est que ce qui se conçoit bien s'énonce
clairement donc quand on a des idées
assez claires sur ce qu'on a envie de
faire en général on est capable de
l'exprimer de manière assez simple et
c'est préférable si on veut susciter
l'adhésion
voilà c'est ça les trois les trois
enseignements principaux de notre apport
c'est des éléments de gestion beaucoup
plus que des mesures précises
on n'a pas dit tiens il faudra limiter
la vitesse à 105 2 sur les autoroutes
merci beaucoup
jean marc jancovici je vais passer la
parole à quand un perrier prenait le
micro qui est juste devant vous et donc
merci pareil en cinq minutes pas plus de
votre point de vue bonjour je m'appelle
quand à bergues et déjà vu très heureux
d'être là je travaille a forci donc
l'institut de l'économie pour le climat
ça s'écrit iccat c'est eux qui a déjà
été cité d'ailleurs et notre travail on
est un institut indépendant et on
travaille à réfléchir à des solutions
pour accélérer la transition énergétique
je pense que c'est notre but à tous ici
est donc dans ces cinq minutes je
voudrais vous présenter trois grands
types d'instruments qu'on peut mobiliser
vous présenter leurs forces et aussi
leurs faiblesses
parce que ça va nourrir un peu les choix
que vous aurez probablement à faire
le premier grand type de levier s'est
mobilisée la fiscalité dans son ensemble
pour inciter et j'insiste sur le dans
son ensemble parce que la fiscalité
c'est quelque chose de très larges et il
ya deux choses en particulier sur
lesquels je voudrais attirer votre
attention
le premier c'est qu'on voit qu'il ya
beaucoup de secteurs qui payent moins
d'impôts que d'autres en particulier sur
les énergies fossiles et ça ça pose une
vraie question par exemple l'aviation
pelle assez peu de taxes les poids
lourds et d'autre on a fait un rapport
où on a passé en revue tout le budget de
l'état et on voit qu'il ya quarante
niches fiscales comme on dit dans le
jargon 40 secteur qui paye moins
d'impôts
ça pose une question d'efficacité ça
poutre économique pour atteindre ses
objectifs et sa pose aussi une question
de justice parce que c'est jamais
agréable de faire des efforts quand son
voisin n'en fait pas la deuxième idée
que je voudrais donc je voudrais vous
parler c'est l'idée que aujourd'hui
on laisse les gens à acheter des
véhicules polluants en les taxant assez
peu au moment de l'achat et on les taxe
beaucoup après à travers les taxes sur
les carburants et finalement quelque
part on crée un peu des prisonniers
énergétique ils ont acheté le véhicule
et une fois qu'ils sont prisonniers en
les taxes donc une possibilité quand on
pense à la fiscalité ce serait peut-être
de taxer un peu plus à l'achat les
véhicules mais aussi les chaudières par
exemple et là il ya beaucoup
d'instruments qui existent ya le bonus
malus qui a été présenté il ya les taxe
sur les cartes grises plein d'options
donc mobiliser la fiscalité un outil qui
peut être très puissant pour inciter
mais a aussi un outil à manier avec
précaution parce qu'on sait qu'il ya des
secteurs qui sont en grande difficulté
le secteur de l'agriculture par exemple
on sait qu'il est déjà étranglés si vous
augmentez les taxes ici comment vont
faire les agriculteurs pour s'adapter
on sait qu'il ya des secteurs qui sont
soumis à une concurrence internationale
forte
l'aviation les poids lourd est là aussi
comment faire je dis pas que c'est pas
possible je dis qu'il faut faire
attention à le faire intelligemment
est typiquement on peut soit taxée
intelligemment
soit on peut aider et ça m'amène sur mon
deuxième point donc premier volet
c'était la fiscalité le deuxième on peut
aider les ménages et les entreprises à
s'adapter
c'est vrai qu'on entend souvent on n'a
pas d'alternative on n'a pas
d'alternative on peut pas à changer et
c'est là que les aides interviennent
dans les halles ya les subventions on
peut subventionner les citoyens pour les
aider à rénover leur maison
on peut subventionner les travaux de
rénovation le changement de chaudière et
on peut aussi les proposer des
alternatives
donc les en investissant c'est-à-dire de
l'investissement public dans les
transports collectifs
il faut investir dans les bus dans les
renouvelables dans le nucléaire dans la
recherche
tout ça pour offrir un peu des
alternatives aux citoyens on a évalué
combien il manqué d'investissement pour
s'aligner avec la stratégie nationale
bas carbone qui a été présentée en
termes de financements publics
on voit qu'il manque 7 à 9 milliards
d'euros ça vous parle peut-être pas 7 à
9 milliards
c'est moins que la taxe d'habitation ces
2 % des dépenses de l'état du budget de
l'état sans parler même du budget des
collectivités nous vous voyez que c'est
un montant qui est pas non plus
excessifs alors aider oui mais avec là
encore un grand point de vigilance
la question c'est d'où vient l'argent
c'est bien de faire des subventions mais
est-ce que vous allez le faire en
faisant de la dette qui sera payée par
les générations futures
est ce que vous allez le faire en
faisant plus d'impôts sachant qu'on voit
quand même qu'il ya déjà une forme de
ras-le-bol fiscale ou est-ce que vous
allez le faire en baissant des dépenses
publiques là quelles dépenses publiques
vous allez baisser la santé l'éducation
enfin voila c'est typiquement le genre
de choix que vous aurez à faire
et enfin le troisième grand levier donc
fiscalité aides les normes et
réglementations bien sûr on voit que
c'est un levier qui est déjà utilisée
par certaines villes qui ont décidé
d'interdire les véhicules diesel à terme
strasbourg a décidé d'interdire les
véhicules diesel en centre-ville en 2025
paris envisage de faire la même chose en
2024 voilà dans les transports donc on
voit aussi qui a décidé d'interdire les
passoires thermiques
ces logements ou vraiment vous sentez le
filet d'air qui passe et la voilà c'est
l'idée d'inciter les propriétaires à
faire des travaux
parce que c'est vrai que il ya toujours
cette question dans fait du locataire
propriétaire
moi j'ai été locataire d'un
à sohar thermique quand j'étais étudiant
j'étais là pour deux ans j'avais ni les
moyens ni l'envié de changer toutes les
fenêtres et la toiture est donc là la
norme peut être une incitation puissante
inciter les propriétaires
certes il faut aussi faire attention que
ça lui coûte très cher à son
propriétaire
parfois c'est des propriétaires qui
habitent leur logement c'est un jeune
couple qui vient de s'endetter jusqu'au
cou pour acheter sa nouvelle maison si
vous lui dites dans deux ans il faut
investir dix mille euros de plus pour
rénover c'est une vraie question comment
on fait et donc là des normes des
réglementations oui mais attention à
vraiment accompagner les ménages et les
entreprises là dedans avec par exemple
des aides et des subventions
donc par rapport à l'objectif de moins
40 % en 2030 je pense qu'on est tous
d'accord qu'il faut accélérer la
transition et j'ai donné plusieurs
exemples dans le secteur des transports
et dans le secteur des logements
parce que d'après le rapport du haut
conseil pour le climat c'est vraiment
deux secteurs clés 50% des émissions où
on est en retard par rapport à nos
objectifs mais il ya d'autres secteurs
et à l'agriculture notamment
donc je vous ai montré qu'il ya de
nombreux leviers qui peuvent être
actionnés davantage la fiscalité les
aides les réglementations mais attention
la façon de le faire
en parallèle je serai capeline en parler
mais je suis convaincu qu'à terme la
question de la taxe carbone est aussi un
outil utile et que tous les outils peut
être utile mais attention il faut pas il
faut là le faire différemment le faire
mieux et d'ailleurs nous on a regardé
comment fait les autres pays à
l'international on a vu que dans
beaucoup de pays la taxe carbone a été
chahuté parfois accepter parfois
rejetées on en a tirées des expériences
notamment sur le fait de il faut être
très transparent dans l' usage des
recettes
il faut vraiment aussi accompagner les
ménages donc rendre rendre visibles les
contreparties et puis savoir s'adapter
parce que chaque pays est différent
voilà de nombreux instruments vous
l'aurez compris aucun n'est parfait tout
seul l'idée c'est vraiment de les
combiner
par exemple et moi j'aime beaucoup c'est
le bonus malus
d'un côté vous taxer et de l'autre vous
taxer les gens qui achètent des
véhicules polluants de l'autre vous
subventionnez les gens qui achètent des
véhicules peu polluants
donc on combine de la fiscalité et des
aides et d'ailleurs on pourrait pourquoi
pas étendre le bonus malus à autre chose
que l'automobile on pourrait le faire
dans la chatte chaudière ou autre j'ai
presque fini
juste dernière doit deuxième exemple
l'histoire des secteurs qui sont plus ou
moins taxé est bien là on pourrait
décider de les taxer tous au même niveau
et utiliser les recettes de ces
nouvelles taxes pour aider les secteurs
à transitionner ou alors prévoir ni sur
les bâtiments prévoir des normes plus
strictes mais un horizon de 10 ans par
exemple en accompagnant d'ici là donc
vraiment la question c'est de trouver le
bon équilibre entre tous ces instruments
merci
[Applaudissements]
kathleen schubert c'est à vous pour cinq
minutes
merci donc je m'appelle câline schubert
je suis professeur d'économie à l'école
d'économie de paris j'appartiens aussi
au conseil pour le climat mais là je
vais pas parler en tant que membre du
conseil pour le climat parce qu'on n'a
pas vraiment discuté de la taxe carbone
encore dans le conseil pour le climat on
n'a pas approfondi la faire donc je vais
parler plutôt sous ma casquette de
professeur d'économie donc ce que je
vais vous dire d'abord c'est qu'il faut
vraiment être conscient de à quel point
les énergies fossiles ont fasciné ont
façonné par dont notre civilisation
en réalité non seulement notre économie
mais toute notre civilisation
il ya quel point c'est dur d'en sortir
pensez aux villes américaines
hyper étendue avec plein de supermarché
dans des banlieues interminables et des
voitures tout le temps personne qui
marche à pied non mais changer ça enfin
en europe c'est un peu moins graves mais
changer ça c'est vraiment d'aider des
choses très très compliqué à faire donc
pour modifier en profondeur notre notre
notre économie et notre façon de vivre
la taxe carbone est un instrument
extrêmement puissant peut pas dire que
ce soit le seul bon j'y reviendrai mais
c'est un acte instrument extrêmement
puissant ça marche extrêmement bien un
tout petit exemple penser à ces petites
différences de fiscalité qui lie à en
france entre le diesel et l'essence ça a
produit diésélisation du parc automobile
de plus de 60%
donc petite différence d'impôts ça a
fait basculer le parc automobile
ça marche très très bien il ya plein
d'autres exemples donc c'est puissant un
instrument très puissant c'est un
instrument qui permet qui incite les
gens à changer de comportement
à condition qu'il puisse le champ qui
pue sans changer donc il faut faire
extrêmement attention qu'il ya des gens
qui te peuvent juste en changer donc
cela il faudra les aînés donc la taxe
carbone c'est puissant mais c'est à
manier avec précaution et c'est un peu
pour ça que c'est impopulaire
donc il faut accompagner la taxe carbone
deux dispositifs qui la rendent juste
ces dispositifs qui la rendent juste
c'est des dispositifs qui aide les gens
qui sont coincés qu'ils peuvent pas du
tout changé au moins à court terme de
comportement
et puis il faut aider les gens qui sont
les plus vulnérables et les plus pauvres
parce que l'énergie ça représente un
plus grand une plus grande part de leur
budget en fait et donc la taxe carbone
va frapper plus durement sur ces gens là
donc il faut les aider et il ya des tas
de moyens de les aider
pourquoi parce qu'en fait évidemment la
taxe carbone va rapporter des recettes
ça va rapporter de l'argent des recettes
fiscales
ces recettes fiscales il n'y a aucune
raison de penser qu'elles doivent
financer le budget général on peut très
bien décider que ses recettes fiscales
vont être utilisé pour compenser les
perdants pour compenser des gens les
plus vulnérables pour rendre la taxe
carbone juste voilà donc c'est vraiment
ça le message je pense je pense
important deuxième point important quand
alain veut dit les ménages les agents
vous et moi on peut se dire pourquoi on
irait paient plein pot la taxe carbone
alors que beaucoup de secteurs
économiques sont exemptés alors que les
entreprises qui payent les quotas du
marché ets paix - prix est beaucoup
moins élevé et que les autres gens dans
les autres pays en chine et aux états
unis ne font aucun effort question
parfaitement légitime donc je crois que
c'est vraiment des questions qu'il faut
se poser pourquoi est ce que nous comme
ça on va accepter de faire ces efforts
donc je pense qu'il faut parallèlement à
la taxe carbone il faut qu'il faut que
les gouvernements fassent des gros
efforts pour que le marché ets marche
mieux que le prix augmente que donc les
entreprises payent une somme équivalente
à ce que payent les ménages ont il ya
moyen de faire ça et sur le plan de
l'effort au niveau international
c'est un peu plus difficile de répondre
à ça mais je pense que 1 vous avez envie
comme moi de pouvoir regarder vos
enfants fassent un plus tard qu'ils
disent pas les parents savait que la
catastrophe allait arriver ils ont rien
fait pour moi ça c'est un point très
important
et puis le deuxième point c'est que
c'est quand même aux pays développés de
faire le premier effort c'est pas aux
indiens ou chinois qui sont pas les
responsables historiques
voilà donc ça ce sont des points
importants ensuite très rapidement il y
a il y à d'autres moyens
il ya les normes les interdictions les
subventions tout un tas d'autres moyens
d'autres instruments dont a parlé
quentin ça peut être parfois utile en
général c'est moins efficace et c'est
plus cher c'est plus coûteux et imaginé
par exemple une norme sur les moteurs
des voitures pour qu'elles soient moins
polluantes
évidemment le constructeur var autres
retranscrire dans le cri le coût de la
norme pour lui et donc ça va faire
augmenter le prix des voitures
donc au final vous allez la payer quand
même cette norme donc la norme même si
le coup est un peu caché a priori va
être aussi coûteuse donc les ménages le
voit moins il accepte mieux les normes
mais il faut faire très attention avec
les normes à cause de ça ça peut coûter
très cher en réalité
mais il ya quand même quelque chose de
certain c'est que la taxe carbone bien
qu'elle soit utile puissante nécessaire
elle ne peut pas suffire elle n'est pas
suffisante
un exemple très simple penser à une taxe
carbone très élevée qui ferait que les
gens passeraient aux voitures
électriques
si on n'a pas au préalable investis pour
mettre des bornes de recharge ça pourra
pas marcher il faut non que les que que
l'état mette en place et investissements
qui seraient complémentaires la taxe
carbone pas de voiture électrique si pas
de bornes de recharge c'est clair et il
y a aussi les investissements dans la
recherche s'cusez moi vous me prenez
pour des enfants et c'est insupportable
pardon vous nous prenez pour des enfants
et vous ça nous paraît insupportable
c'est insupportable ce que vous nous
faites entendre
j'ai pas j'ai pas je vous prends pour
des enfants
je prends pas pour des enfants c
je sais plus trop que dire là du coup
j'avais pas cette impression mais des
choses que vous savez en tant qu'expert
mais pas que il faut mettre des prises
électriques ça aucun intérêt on a dit
que c'était une urgence climatique on a
besoin d'une réponse concrète des choses
importantes
alors moi je suis pas ici venu pour
encore entendre des prises électriques
merci
mais parlons trop de la taxe carbone
mais alors qu'ils viennent de faire deux
questionnaires avec la taxe carbone ce
et 2 comment deux intervenants toujours
avec la taxe carbone
nous sommes là pour le climat ou dit
nous vous voulez nous emmener s'il vous
plaît nulle part non mais pas vous
spécialement madame mais dites nous où
vous voulez vous emmener avec cette
convention messieurs et mesdames les
organisateurs moi j'en ai plus rien j'ai
un questionnaire questions sur la taxe
carbone premier jour
première question sur la taxe carbone
donc deux fois deux intervenants taxe
car voilà merci
alors s'il vous plaît oui ou non il
n'est pas d'entre deux s'il vous plaît
ce que madame schubert est en train de
vous expliquer là c'est que tout se
tient c'est pas c'est pas parce que elle
vous explique des choses simples
qu'elles vous prend pour des enfants
dans ce que nous avons à faire il y a
des choses d'une très grande simplicité
il y a des choses d'une très grande
technicité et les deux vont ensemble et
vous avez besoin de travailler sur les
deux c'est pas parce que c'est simple
que ses bêtes
il ya des choses qui sont complexes et
qui sont très utiles il ya des choses
qui sont complexes et qui le sont moins
et indiqué que si l'état subventionne
beaucoup les acheteurs de voitures pour
qu ils puissent avoir des voitures
électriques mais que par ailleurs
personne ne s'occupe de faire en sorte
que ces voitures électriques puissent se
recharger c'est pas vous prendre pour
des enfants c'est simplement montrer que
la subvention tout seul ne suffit pas et
que essais et c'est ça que l'on que l'on
essaye de voir cet après midi c'est que
les instruments fonctionnent quand ils
sont pris dans un ensemble quand ils
peuvent être agencée combiner les uns
avec les autres donc ce que je vous
demande s'il vous plaît c'est d'écouter
de kathleen va terminer en quelques en
quelques secondes puis ensuite de poser
des questions vous pouvez mettre en
cause ce que l'on vous dit c'est pas la
question
aucune personne qui est venu ici ne vous
prend pour des enfants qui que vous
soyez personnes simplement
soyez attentifs à ce qui est élevé ce
qui est compliqué et ce qui est simple
les deux sont utiles catherine vous
concluez
on vous entend pas madame vous avez pas
de micros
oui mais alors si madame merci madame
joubert effectivement nous devons
prendre position pour donner des
solutions qui soit juste socialement et
l'exposé de madame était justement pour
que nous faisions attend ce pas une
façon attention à à prendre des mesures
a déterminé des faire des propositions
qui soient justes et donc scission vais
des caricatures de climat c'est pas bien
ça c'est pas bien ça bon on ne sera
jamais alors sérieux s'il vous plaît à
l'intention de ville ce n'est pas
seulement mon voirie encore devant nous
et messieurs si l'intervention qu'on
peut faire est-ce que alors on a besoin
d'avoir une règle entre nous parce que
sinon on va pas y arriver
vous avez tous un micro donc vous pouvez
tous prendre la parole quand vous voulez
parfait sauf que si vous prenez tous la
parole en même temps dans dix minutes on
ne s'entend plus donc je vous demande
d'avoir la gentillesse de suivre une
règle très simple si vous voulez parlez
vous faites connaître vous vous levez
vous manifester et je vous donnerai la
parole pas forcément dans la seconde
parce qu'il faut aussi qu'on avance mais
je vous donnerai la parole premier point
deuxième point qui est une mise au point
là pour le coup on vient de faire
référence à un questionnaire ce
questionnaire c'est le questionnaire des
chercheurs ce n'est pas le nôtre
nous ne sommes pas responsables des
questions qui sont dedans nous n'avons
pas rédigé et nous n'allons pas les
analyses et les chercheurs vous pose des
questions pour leurs besoins de
recherche qui sont ce qu'ils sont vous
pouvez en penser ce que vous voulez et
même m ce que vous pensez sur le
questionnaire en le rendant vous avez
tout à fait la possibilité de le faire
et je vous rappelle que c'est un
questionnaire qui n'est pas obligatoire
vous y répondez uniquement si vous
souhaitez y répondre je vous demande
maintenant d'avoir la gentillesse
écouter les mots de conclusion de de
catherine de kathleen schubert pardon et
ensuite on va passer à la phase de
fabrication des questions alesi kathleen
non mais je n'ai plus rien à dire je
voulais surtout pas c'était absolument
pas mon intention de prendre qui compte
pour des enfants
voilà je voulais quand même peut-être
dire une sûr d'une chose pour terminer
c'est que comme on l'a
bienvenue dans le conseil pour le climat
il faut que l'ensemble des politiques
publiques soit aligné vers la même vers
le même objectif
c'est à dire que ça sert pas forcément à
grand chose que de faire des politiques
environnementales des politiques
climatiques très pointu si par ailleurs
les autres politiques publiques les
politiques de transport les politiques
d'aménagement urbain tirs dans un autre
dans une autre direction
voilà il faut vraiment un alignement des
politiques merci beaucoup
catherine joubert merci à
merci à tous les 3es et à tous les
quatre mêmes qui avaient pris la parole
donc maintenant on a vous avez fini
d'écouter ou plus exactement vous avez
vous allez passer dans une deuxième
phase qui est une phase dans laquelle on
vous propose de je vous donnais parle
tout de suite on vous propose de mettre
au point les questions vous souhaitez
poser à noosa nous invitez vous le
faites par groupe de 6 un peu comme vous
l'aviez fait la dernière fois donc ceux
qui sont en bas se lève pour pouvoir
discuter avec ceux qui sont rendus
dessus vous écrivez une question ou un
commentaire par feuille de papier on les
ramasse tous de façon à ce que les
quatre personnes qui vont les les
organiser alors je vous demande de vous
bat de venir avec moi ici donc j'appelle
m'at-il dit mr et léo cohen les deux
membres du cos rouve et puis les deux
messieurs venez avec moi je ne vois pas
votre prénom 10 6 pierre et alors il
réfléchit trop du coup il n'entend pas
le monsieur qui est juste derrière la
wii
j'ai vu madame la garante j'ai vu donc
j'ai donc
venez rejoignez-nous peau non non donc
je donne la parole à mademoiselle là-bas
à mathieu ici et puis ensuite vous
passez aux questions on écoute
mademoiselle merci de vous présenter
donc je suis marine de metz ça fait déjà
plusieurs fois je constate que comme des
personnes prennent la parole
c'est totalement le droit ont un ton
agressif je pense que c'est pas le but
de cette convention n'est là pour
débattre
mais
5 a vraiment qui sont venus ici souvenu
pour nous expliquer certaines choses on
n'a pas tous le même niveau
forcément intellectuelle à certains
niveaux donc je pense que c'est très
bien justement qui puisse expliquer les
choses faisant détails que vous trouvez
peut-être simple pour d'autres c'est
peut-être pas aussi simple donc juste
moi personnellement ce que j'apprécie et
je pense que beaucoup de monde
apprécierez ici c'est que quand on prend
la parole on essaie d'avoir un taux un
peu plus chaleureux mois moins sur la
défensive
- sur l'agressivité enfin je pense que
c'est vraiment ce qu'on souhaite tous
ici pour que ça fonctionne le mieux
[Musique]
merci merci beaucoup
mathieu à la parole wima mathieu mathieu
de lyon moi je vais je voulais juste
faire une petite parenthèse
aujourd'hui on vient nous parler de
voiture électrique alors que déjà d'une
des voitures électriques
c'est fait avec des batteries au lithium
ion sais même pas quoi en faire non
c'est pas ça le problème
aujourd'hui vous venez vous nous
témoignez je suis totalement d'accord
avec ça avec tout le respect que je vous
dois
mais aujourd'hui il existe de l'énergie
libre tels que la fusion froide jean
christophe dumas et plein d'autres ces
gens là ils sont paul cote depuis des
années voire persécutés on leur a tout
fait perdre et c'est pas nous les
citoyens qui sommes responsables de cela
c'est le gouvernement est aujourd'hui
faut que ça cesse parce qu'aujourd'hui
les solutions et les a et faut que ça
s'arrête tout simplement merci et merlin
il ya plein de choses
l'un des brevets qui sont mises au
placard et j'aimerais bien savoir
pourquoi
et aussi est-ce que vous êtes vous
contrôlez par des lobbys alors merci
contrôlés par des lobbys alors merci
mathieu ce que ce que je propose c'est
qu'on rentre pas de cette manière là
dans le débat donc j'entends cette
romain madame là-haut souhaitait
intervenir
vous intervenez sip aussi si possible
pour lancer le débat maintenance mais
plutôt pour dire quelque chose sur notre
fonctionnement
ou alors on passe à la fabrication des
questions un groupe de six allez-y
ile-de-france bien dans le devant le
micro bonjour annihile le prend sens
c'est juste pour réagir effectivement
sur l'intervention en fait c'est un
sentiment c'est par de l'agressivité je
pense que les gens sont authentiques et
réagissent à frouard je pense pas qu'il
faille donner l'interprétation à la
façon de réagir et
par contre sur le fonctionnement ce
n'est pas à moi de vous dire comment
cela fonctionnait mais mon ressenti par
rapport à l'intervention
de madame schubert et à commencer par
maudire je vais mettre en avant à mon
côté économie et pour faire changer
aujourd'hui des attitudes en profondeur
voilà ma façon de voir les choses et
elle est rentrée tout de suite sur la
taxe carbone avant d'avoir un ensemble
ça veut dire en tant qu'économiste on
commence peut-être alors une vue
d'ensemble
il ya des choses qui vont être priorisés
et donc c'est pour ça que cette
sensation tout de suite
à noter les guidances parce que vous
êtes rentré sur une problématique en
ciblant uniquement la taxe carbone et je
reviens sur l'exemple de mathieu on nous
parle de l'alternative de la voiture
électrique sans nous en donner toutes
les mesures donc à la rigueur venez dire
voilà ce que je pense sur un poids et je
prends un exemple concret donc ça je
trouve pas que ça remettre en question
ce que vous dites mais ça explique aussi
un peu hâlé réaction merci merci
beaucoup
alors donc ce que je vous propose
il est 17h29 je vous propose de prendre
dix minutes je j'ai vu je donne la
consigne je vous donne la parole et vous
travaillez je vous propose de prendre
dix minutes par groupe de 6 pour rédiger
les questions on va passer dans les
rangs pour récupérer des questions les
quatre personnes deux volontaires plus
de membres du comité de gouvernance vont
prendre dix minutes un quart d'heure
pour organiser le questionnement et
pendant ce temps là vous pourrez
continuer d' interdit de poser des
questions de façon individuelle
le jeune homme qui est là-haut à la
parole pour deux demi seconde
oui alors c'est très très courageux pose
la question parce que en tant que lycéen
je gère désormais attendez on vous
écoute pas assez je donne la parole à ce
jeune homme voulait écouter et avez vous
travaillé alors je peux nicolas je viens
des bouches du rhône j'en profites poser
une petite question parce que c'était
très intéressant si on devait raconter
je vais être un peu ça c'est avec tout
le monde
j'ai pas compris la moitié des trucs
parce que bon hein faut être réaliste
mais mais du coup je voulais poser une
question qui me concerne moi et mes
camarades de mon lycée dans les bouches
du rhône
on a étudié l'an dernier en fin d'année
de première les batteries notamment un
avion qui roulait qui volait vers des
voitures qui roulent et au vin etc
donc on parle je rebondis sur ce deal
monsieur tout à l'heure au niveau des
batteries lithium et c'est donc long
qu'on roule électrique on roule vers en
france mais les batteries lithium en
fait on prélève le lithium dans des pays
comme la bolivie intérieur sert à ça
coûte cher déjà de d'extraire ce lithium
on pollue et les usines de raffinage et
c est en fait ma question c'était savoir
comment on va régler ça parce qu'on nous
parle beaucoup aujourd'hui des voitures
électriques que celles à venir etc
mais pour l'instant tout ce qu'on a
constaté c'est qu'on a délocalisé cette
pollution dans un autre pays et je veux
savoir s'il y avait une solution à sa
merci merci nicolas
merci nicolas je propose qu'on prenne
cette question dans le paquet de celles
qui vont être traités par la suite et je
vous demande si vous le voulez bien de
faire comme nos amis qui sont ici de
vous mettre au travail pour dix minutes
je reviens vers vous à 42
ça
ce
ce que nous allons faire c'est pendant
que vos deux collègues et les demandes
du comité de gouvernance organise les
questionnements
nous allons demander à nos intervenants
nous inviter de répondre aux questions
individuelles qui ont été posées tout à
l'heure par écrit vous les avez là alors
je sais pas si on pourra tout les
traiter parce que tu es qu'ils auront
terminé le traitement des questions
collectives
on passera en priorité aux questions
collectives d'accord mais en attendant
on va voir pour les questions
individuelles et c'est alors elles sont
écrites ici mais c'est ma collègue
sophie qui va vous les voulez poser les
unes après les autres
je te donne un micro micro rouge pour
que tu puisse poser la première question
ce que je vous demande
kathleen et jean marc laurent et quentin
c'est si possible de faire des réponses
assez courte pour qu'on puisse traiter
le maximum de questions
sophie tu nous lis la première question
s'il te plaît alors je voulais avoir les
prénoms mais on les a par noter vous
même fort vous m'entendez là alors au
sujet des aides
on se demandait si on ne peut pas
trouver un autre système que les aide
parce que elles ne vont jamais ou
rarement au bon endroit et aux bonnes
personnes en fait elle n'arrive pas là
où on espérerait quelles aides qu'elles
arrivent là qui peut répondre à cette
question
quentin
alors il faudrait qu'on garde tous les
micros ouverts si c'était possible en
tribune
s'il vous plaît un micro blanc qui doit
fonctionner la région là oui oui c'est
bon oui mais alors sur la question des
aides effectivement une aide
il faut toujours être très prudent avec
il faut bien la calibrer si vous mettez
des êtres trop généreuse typiquement sur
le bonus malus si vous mettez un bonus
trop généreux ou une prime à la
conversion trop généreuses sur des
véhicules même moyennement polluants
vous allez encourager les gens à changer
plus vite de véhicules avec toutes les
émissions liées à la fabrication des
véhicules électriques ou non est donc là
vous voyez qu'on a un effet
contre-productif donc une aide doit
toujours être très bien pensée très bien
ciblé effectivement c'est pour ça que
c'est difficile de répondre de façon
générale à cette question les aides sont
un outil utile avec les autres que j'ai
mentionnés dans l'esprit d'une panoplie
d'instruments sur les suv je pense pas
qu'ils aient des suv et bénéficie des
donc je suis un peu surpris mais voilà
enfin je pense avoir mentionné les
autres instruments
c'est pour ça que j'ai surpris je
voulais juste d'accord avec la question
dans l'idée que il faut vraiment bien
calibrer les aides merci quand un autre
question il y avait une question sur les
normes européennes qui semblent très
souvent énergivores en tout cas qu'elle
par exemple pour les artisans
ils ont le sentiment que on a du
matériel qui devient aux normes mais
qu'il leur est pas assez longtemps et
donc du coup on se voit obligé pour
certains artisans par exemple de
l'électricité des chaudières etc
on se voit obligé au bout d'un moment
finalement quand on est artisan de les
détruire de les jeter et donc quelqu'un
disait que c'était muriel que on avait
du coup un coût d'émission à la
fabrication et ensuite un coût
d'émission à la destruction à l'utilité
de ces de ce matériel donc en gros le
rythme des normes qui allait beaucoup
trop vite par rapport aux finalement à
l'utilisation qui répond
bon on va se répartir ou completel et la
question des réglementations séquelles
pas qu une question d équilibre
effectivement si on avait clôturé à
l'extrême une norme qui dit que sur les
chaudières on doit les changer tous les
cinq ans parce qu'il ya une amélioration
de l'efficacité non seulement ces
coûteux mais effectivement aussi on a
les pollutions générées par les la
fabrication néanmoins assez souvent il y
a quand même peu d'interdiction ou
d'obligation de détruire quelque chose
que vous avez acheté par contre
effectivement on ne trouve plus sur le
marché des matériels d'ancienne
génération art en place voilà il peut y
avoir effectivement paraît donc chose
qui est très dommageable c'est ce qui
pourrait être ce qu'on appelait parfois
l'obsolescence programmée ou fait que
des matériels ne vivent pas longtemps
parce que là pour le coup il faut les
remplacer et on a des idées et mes
émissions donc c'est aussi vraiment des
questions secteur par secteur
3 un bon équilibre entre le progrès des
déréglementations là où il ya ces
réglementations et les capacités
d'adaptation essayer de développer
fectivement aussi des approches un peu
global de dire ben oui c'est il n'y a
pas que le matériel lui même il ya tout
ce qu'il a pu générer sans appel
l'analyse de cycle de vie
c'est mais s'il prend le les véhicules
autres c'est un mieux d'avoir un
véhicule vivent pas 150 ans donc fait
que les véhicules neufs progresse même
si la direction qui disent après que
c'est pas si évident
c'est une bonne chose donc il ya des
questions d'équilibré dans l'évolution
des réglementations
merci un mot là-dessus j'en ai très vite
juste pour dire qu'en fait d'abord
toutes les normes même dans les
matériels qui sont concernés par la
chose climatique toutes les normes ne
sont pas fait pour des raisons
climatiques
donc il peut y avoir des normes qui vont
à l'encontre de l'objectif climatique
parce que la raison d'avoir fait la
norme c'était autre chose que l'objectif
climatique
la deuxième
la deuxième chose c'est en fait de cas
pas que c'est même assez peu fréquent il
ya des domaines dans lesquels je prends
l'exemple des transports le fait de des
sulfures et les carburants
on utilise pour le transport automobile
engendre une surconsommation d'énergie
dans la raffinerie parce que c'est là
que ça se passe
parce que pour ça on a besoin de
fabriquer de l'hydrogène qui va servir à
des sulfures et le carburant
donc on gagne quelque chose sur la
pollution locale on n'a pas de soufre
dans le carburant donc on n'a pas de
dioxyde de soufre dans l'émission du pot
d'échappement
par contre on a perdu au niveau du co2
puisque la raffinerie doit consommer
plus d'énergie pour des sulfures et le
carburant alors c'est un exemple qui est
très très loin de la question qui a été
posée je suis pas du tout dans le
matériel électrique qui arrive chez vous
mais c'est juste pour vous faire
comprendre que des normes
il y en a plein qui sont décidés par
plein de gens et la cohérence avec le
sujet climatique
elle est très rarement regardé par des
gens qui édicte des normes quand ils
sont pas directement dans le sujet et
même quand ils sont directement dans le
sujet c'est pas sûr
merci alors je sais sur cette question
là que voulait intervenir deux secondes
alors justement merci de vous présenter
deux graves eric melun 77
alors justement dans d'autres domaines
d'activité au niveau européen il y à une
réglementation qui impose à l'exploitant
ou aux producteurs de démontrer qu'ils
utilisent les meilleures techniques
disponibles que ce soit le bref que ce
soit le reach sur les substances
toxiques
est ce que l'europe travaille pour que
on impose aux industriels lorsqu'une
techniques existent industriels pour
décarbonée est ce qu'il ya une
réglementation européenne qui est en
cours des réflexions qui sont en cours
pour imposer justement aux industries de
pouvoir être obligés d'utiliser ou de
basculer vers ses meilleures techniques
qui sont qui serait non non non
carbonées merci
vous avez une réponse à cette question
alors ça dépend ce que vous appelez un
industrie il ya j'ai évoqué le système
des quotas d'émission de co2 qui
concerne les industries
ça va de la production d'électricité
jusqu'au cimenterie en passant par des
papeteries qui émettent beaucoup de co2
le choix qui a été fait c'est de
diminuer globalement et ensuite avec des
réductions se canet et qui se peuvent
être différenciées par secteur le par
rapport à la production ce qu'on est
autorisée à émettre donc d'une façon
c'est une façon d'exprimer le fait qu'on
va vers les meilleures techniques des
disponibles ça nécessite un réglage si
on est trop mou on va dire si on dit
c'est moins un demi pour cent par an
selon les cotes le volume de quotas de
co2 ça on suit pas le rythme si on dit
c'est moins 10% par an ça va aussi
évidemment trop vite sur ce qui est
plutôt là le produit on va dire le
véhicule mais aussi les chaudières les
équipements électriques là pour le coup
beau dans beaucoup de secteurs pour des
aspects pollution des aspects sécurité
ou co2 il ya une exigence minimale qui
reflète presque la meilleure technique
aux usa on n'a plus le droit de vendre
un certain nombre d'équipements trop
énergivores dans divers domaines dont là
il ya des obligations sanaa et idem pour
les armes pour les véhicules lourds
sahara été adoptée l'année dernière les
poids lourds qu'on va aller vers des
réductions
donc il ya des choix qui font l'objet de
nombreux débats qui
au niveau européen d'essayer de trouver
un ou plusieurs instruments
quand il s'agit de réglementation les
quotas de co2 c'est une réglementation
aussi parfois c'est par la technique
parfois c'est par l'objectif merci
beaucoup autre question sauf ici on va
regrouper deux il ya quelqu'un qui a dit
d'une part à part dont vous parlez de
l'impact carbone des importations en
fait on a ce souci du fait qu'un grand
nombre de nos entreprises ont été
décodés localiser vous fermez donc du
coup comment se dire que c'est un
problème d'avoir cet impact carbone des
importations et d'autre part il ya une
personne qui demandait aussi pourquoi
l'allocation des quotas gratuits est
prévue dans le cadre d'une
délocalisation des entreprises sur le
marché pour éviter que du coup elle soit
être soumise à la concurrence pour
éviter qu'elle se donnait délocalisent
il a été question dans votre
présentation du fait qu'on pouvait
éviter de leur forme et des quotas
d'émission laurent
oui alors je vais donc continuer enfin
prendre la dernière question où va ou
dira première j'avais évoqué sélection
de l'empreinte carbone est une des
réponses mais qui ne s'est pas si simple
de dire mais éveillant une
relocalisation d'une partie de
production en europe et en france peut
avoir un effet positif sur notre
empreinte carbone et où il faut aussi se
dire que les produits qu'on va faire
pendant les 30 ans qui viennent
faut que les usines soient là bon après
il ya des cas des spécialisations par
pays il ya des différences de conditions
j'ai pas sûr qu'on soit capable de tout
relocaliser c'est aussi avoir des choses
qui soient moins au sol est rapidement
terre sort sur les quotas de co2
effectivement ainsi il a été décidé au
niveau or pas que dans tous les
émetteurs que j'ai cités il ya des
grands il y en a certaines qui ont une
concurrence internationale tels que le
prix du carbone peut peser beaucoup et
donc générer un risque de délocalisation
concurrence vraiment très difficile ceux
là ont effectivement par rapport ils ont
un certain volume de quotas gratuits
mais parce qu'ils ne couvrent jamais
100% et qui va de toute façon en se
réduisant donc le législateur européen
et c'est de dire que
quand vous êtes en très écrit d'action
sociale n'avait plus de quotas gratuits
quand vous l'êtes moins vous en avez
moins mais qu'on essaye et après il ya
d'autres réflexions européenne est ce
que on pourrait pas avoir une sorte de
certains appellent taxe aux frontières
mécanisme d'action carbone un moyen
quelque part de demander aux produits
importés d'être soumis aux mêmes
standards mais juste pour dire c'est
extrêmement compliqué c'est quoi le
standard d'une tonne de ce fait si vous
faites une tonne de ciment c'est quoi
son standard des maîtres en termes
d'émissions de co2 c'est des sujets qui
y sont évoquées dont classe il faut
c'est de trouver un équilibre parce que
à l'extrême sud à moi je suis exposé aux
risques de karm de fuite de carbone et
j'ai hâte vitam aeternam tous mes quotas
gratuits sans progrès rien n'avancera
donc c'est une question de curseur et
qui est loin d'être simple et peut dire
que ça n'a pas toujours été efficace
parfois trop dur parfois pas assez dure
voilà merci
autre question oui j'en fais jean-claude
un quiz jean-claude oui c'est ça que ça
qu'on sait je reviens sur les aides au
lieu de parler des deux subventions
c'est à dire que c'est toujours l'argent
public donc match que j'aimerais savoir
c'est pourquoi que vous intéressez pas
au prix de sortie d'une usine d'une
voiture parce que je rebondis garde un
petit peu sur internet ils vous disent
de l'idée sortie des usines de voitures
sont entre cinq et sept mille euros
quand vous faites le tour des donc on en
essence et en diesel soit 15 à 20 mm ou
lavande et une électrice et 30 mai
donc je procéderai là on parle de
subventions dette pour les voitures pour
revenir là dessus donc ça on joue avec
de l'argent public se dire qu'on donne
de l'argent mais moi ce que j'aimerais
savoir c'est combien coûte une voiture
sortie des usines au départ aller de
crise réduction d'une voiture voilà
parce que là ce qu'ils voulaient à mon
avis c'est plus une culbute qui font
quoi donc ça ce serait mettre les
industries à participer quand même assez
c'est une idée alors est ce que
quelqu'un sait quel est le taux de marge
finalement c'est ça qu'on demande c'est
une en une entreprise qui vend des
voitures combien de la voiture lui coûte
la production et du coup combien l'avant
et quelle est la différence entre les
deux est ce qu on a une idée de sa
jean-marc jean-marc attention parce que
c'est une question là il se lance dans
le vide
je me lance complètement cents fidèles
traditionnellement les coûts de
distribution pour à peu près n'importe
quoi ça se promène entre 10 et 30% et je
vois pas tellement de raisons pour
lesquelles pour une voiture ça sortirait
de cette fourchette mais peut-être que
dans très exactement une demi heure je
vais arrêter de vous avoir donné cette
réponse mais voilà je pense que ça doit
être ça lors de grandeur j'ai juste une
touche aussi parce que l'idée c'est
comment faire baisser le prix du
véhicule c5 nation mais je reviens ils
ont tué vous prenez bouche qu'on paye ça
parce qu'on perd on est en france
ils ont délocalisé en roumanie donc
anormalement le coût de production est
moins cher mais pas contre les voitures
moi j'ai prévu que vous avez descendu
d'impact c'est pas faux merci question
suivante sauf s il te plaît et à une
question assez techniques au sujet de la
captation et du stockage de carbone
alors il a été question vous avez parlé
de la forêt mais quelqu'un a compris
qu'il était aussi question du stockage
du carbone dans le sol et voulait
comprendre comment ça s'effectuer qu'est
ce que c'était et quels sont les
bénéfices de telles pratiques versus les
risques alors l'enfouissement du carbone
jean-marc jancovici ça je peux répondre
mais du coup je vais faire un hold up je
vais finir doré quand vous délocalisez
une usine en roumanie en fait ce que
vous savez c'est que l'assemblage va se
faire en roumanie mais vous savez que
les constructeurs autos sont fournis par
des équipementiers les usines des
équipementiers peuvent être ailleurs et
donc le fait que vous soyez en roumanie
change pas nécessairement le prix
d'achat des pièces parce que ce qu'on
appelle des constructeurs auto en fait
c'est des assembleurs finaux mais ils
font pas tout les toutes les pièces
avant sont faites par des équipements
qui voilà donc je suis pas en train de
vous donner une réponse nécessairement
très satisfaisante
juste en train de vous dire c'est pas
juste parce que s'est délocalisée dans
un pays que c'est facile d'en déduire
comment varie le coup d'assemblage le
coup de global de la voiture
non mais là je passais sur l'assèchement
de la mer je propose que sur cette
question je vous ai parlé tous les deux
la sortie alors ce qu'on appelle la
capture du co2 en fait il ya une chose à
laquelle on pense jamais mais qui est
très simple qui s'appelle planter les
arbres mais c'est ça entre en
concurrence avec les surfaces qu'on
occupe pour nos cultures alimentaires et
ça entre tellement en concurrence qu'en
fait dans une planète où la démographie
augmente celle inverse ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'un peu
partout surface de la terre en coupe des
arbres pour faire des nouvelles surfaces
cultivables pour nourrir une population
en croissance
donc cette marge de manoeuvre là pour le
moment marche pas trop bien et elle
marche d'autant moins bien que le début
du changement climatique qu'on observe
actuellement sur terre est en train de
rendre de plus en plus difficile
l'existence des écosystèmes donc des
arbres il ya malheureusement une
publication qui est sorti il ya quelques
années
bah il ya quelques semaines pardon dans
la littérature scientifique qui montre
que depuis 2000 la capacité des forêts
dans le monde à reprendre une partie du
co2 qu'on met dans l'atmosphère s'est
fortement affaiblie donc les puits
naturels commencent à souffrir
donc ça c'est la manière la plus simple
et la plus triviale j'ai envie de dire
après il ya une manière technologique
qui a été poussé en avant qui consiste à
récupérer le co2 directement en sortie
des cheminées des endroits où il ya de
grosses émissions de co2 donc les
centrales à charbon les cimenteries et
c'est pour essayer de récupérer co2 et
de le mettre sous terre voilà c'est ça
qu'on pense en général alors la grosse
limite de ce processus c'est que pour
attraper le co2 qui est une molécule
inerte dans la fumée il faut dépenser de
l'énergie
parce qu'il n'a aucune envie de voilà
c'est comme les enzymes de coluche lie à
aucune envie de venir tout seul donc
faut l'attraper et il faut dépenser 30 %
de l'énergie qui est autrement utilisé
par la centrale où la cimenterie ce qui
veut dire que si vous mettez ce procédé
en oeuvre va vous allez avoir 30 %
d'électricité en moins derrière votre
centrale
donc il faut voir comment est-ce qu'on
répartisse et économie ou alors il faut
réussir à mettre dans une centrale 40%
de charbon en plus et c'est très
compliqué parce que la logistique du
charbon c'est un truc qui est
indémodable
donc c'est un processus auquel beaucoup
de gens pensent aujourd'hui vous avez
quelques prototypes qui tourne dans le
monde et la probabilité que ce soit
déployée à large échelle avant que vos
enfants et votre âge et malheureusement
pas très élevé merci oui quentin et
essayer le micro qui est devant vous
cottage juste pour compléter un tout
petit point ça c'est les deux grandes
techniques effectivement et aussi dans
l'agriculture des options on a assez peu
parlé d'agriculture jusqu'à présent mais
on peut on sait qu'il ya des
possibilités de changer un peu les
pratiques agricoles pour capter un peu
plus de co2 dans la terre voilà les
prairies finalement capte pas mal de co2
en plus des forêts où ils oublient
parfois merci question suivante s'il te
plaît juste on est en train de vérifier
où en étaient les groupes qui faisait la
synthèse de vos questions il ya 150
questions ils ont traité 12
donc on va traiter celles ci vous voyez
le problème de la densité d'informations
on essaye d'être au moins transparents
sur tout ce qu'on reçoit donc on va
prendre celles qui sont à l'écran mais
du coup et calais
écrivez tout allez-y victor de bourgogne
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec
vous puisque maintenant il ya une
nouvelle technique qui est sorti en
espagne où il récupère le
le co2 pour créer du pétrole à base
d'algues
voilà ce qu'ils rentabilisent ray le
système c'est aussi quelque chose qu'on
qui est fait c'est à dire que vous
utilisez des végétaux marins donc des
algues et vous les nourrices et en gros
avec du co2 en les mettant dans des
conditions favorables
alors ça ça vous permet pas de capturer
le co2 pour le mettre sous terre donc de
plus en entendre parler
vous allez le mettre dans des halles qui
vont vous faire de la grèce c'est des
machines à faire de la grèce
les algues avec ça vous allez faire des
carburants et ces carburants vous allez
évidemment les brûler donc en fait vous
allez finir par mettre le co2 dans l'air
mais vous en serez servi deux fois
quelque part et effectivement c'est une
technique qui permet d'améliorer quelque
part le l'efficacité
globale du processus pourrait absolument
mais pour le moment c'est des
dispositifs expérimentaux et en fait le
problème que dont vous êtes en train de
discuter c'est des problèmes d'ordre de
grandeur c'est à dire est que quand on
sait faire un truc on sait en faire un
million non mais c'est toujours ça le
même problème c'est quand la technologie
permet de mettre au point un dispositif
est ce que c'est très facile ou pas d'en
faire un dispositif qui changera le
quotidien de tous les gens qui sont ici
ou pas
c'est plus une question de volonté je
pense des fois c'est aussi un poil de
physique c'est là que ça devient
inquiétant
quentin rapidement et oui encore une
fois pour compléter parce que je vois
que la question il y avait deux
questions en fait c'est quels sont les
bénéfices et les risques de la captation
et du stockage alors sur le fait de
planter des arbres il ya un vrai risque
qui est la permanence parce que si vous
payez aujourd'hui pour planter de
l'armée qui est un incendie demain et
ben voilà tout est relâché donc il faut
vraiment être faire attention à ça sur
le fait d'enfouir le co2 avec du captage
et stockage un peu technologique
là il ya vraiment la question de qui va
payer pour ça parce qu'on voit que les
gens ont pas trop hein ça a été
difficile de payer pour des énergies
renouvelables alors qui va payer pour
capter du co2 qui est dans l'atmosphère
dans sa pose cette question plus à long
terme est ce qu'il va pas y avoir des
risques de fuites mais les ingénieurs
disent qu a priori c'est bon mais on
peut toujours se poser la question
merci pour coup question suivante c'est
pas du tout ce que je veux dire au
contraire je pense que c'est très
important de ralentir la déforestation
de re leur faut rester là où il y avait
des forêts même dafoe rester là où il y
avait pas de forêt il faut vraiment le
faire
c'est juste que dans les risques il faut
savoir qu'il ya des risques d'incendié
etc
mais c'est clairement quelque chose
qu'il faut faire et merci question
suivante sophie il y avait une question
sur
le permis d'achat d'émissions de co2 en
fait vous avez évoqué des coups qui
allait augmenter on était à quelques
euros la tonne et on allait vers 50
voire 100 euros la tonne et donc
quelqu'un se demandait s'il fallait pas
bloquer l'achat de
de permis d'émissions en avance parce
que ça pouvait risquer ça risquerait de
créer des processus de spéculation sur
le prix de la taxe carbone alors il ya
des dispositifs qui sont là juste pour
pour empêcher ça sachant que quand vous
avez un marché à un moment il y a
toujours des gens qui sont vendeurs et
et d'autres acheteurs le dispositif a
évolué ces derniers temps dans l'idée
qu'enfin il l'était déjà avant mais en
fait des quotas y'en a pas un nombre
infini qui sont mis en 10 mai sur le
marché chaque année ils sont mis aux
enchères sur le marché
ce nombre décroît et il ya à partir de
2021 je me rappelle jamais ça commence
fin 2020 ou début 2011 à un pardon
désolé j'ai un trou il y aura même un
dispostif quand constatera qu'il ya trop
de quotas au niveau européen sur le
marché ils vont on en mettra moins aux
enchères pour pour à la fois évité si en
a trop le christ de pc donc les gens
vont moins investir mais aussi et éviter
ces achats massifs de personnes qui
auraient tellement acheter que certains
chefs après dans cet intervalle il ya
effectivement des gens qui va peut-être
achèteront plus parce qu'ils pensent
avoir besoin de quotas arrivée - à
émettre et d'autres qui vont peut-être
effectivement vouloir peut-être un peu
spéculer le sait spéculer comporte aussi
des risques cavaillé
et dont il ya une limite en volume et il
ya il ya des prix si les prix augmentent
si vous prenez des risques quand même
mais le but c'est effectivement pas de
créer des espèces de bulles ou quelqu'un
ferait un énorme stock donc oui il ya un
mécanisme qui n'est pas parfait parce
que on se dit aussi valable s'il y en a
qui en achètent
ça maintient le prix voilà tous à votre
merci sophy il y avait une série de
remarques qui consistait à dire que
l'état et l'europe
faux confiance aux constructeurs
automobiles mais nous on finalement on
paye des histoires comme le dialecte
gate et que c'est nous qui sommes
désignés comme des pollueurs donc d'une
certaine manière c'est facile pour
l'état de deux taxes et l'état en fait à
travers tout ce qu'il fait ne répond pas
à nos propres difficultés
il a de l'argent pour mettre des radars
mais il n'a pas de l'argent pour
installer des bornes de recharge
électrique donc en fait en gros il y
avait tout un sujet autour d'eux qu'est
ce que peut faire l'état pour finalement
s'occuper plus de nous
c'est à dire une question car au maroc a
vraiment marre qu'on notera
effectivement dans le compte rendu et
derrière ça il y avait aussi on nous a
orientés finalement vers la
mondialisation et aujourd'hui on nous
demande de faire des pas en arrière
ouais
et est ce que est ce qu'on peut prendre
peut-être là la dernière question là de
façon comptable
le prix du permis d'émissions et la taxe
sur le prix carbone reviennent au même
pourquoi privilégier un marché des
permis alors que cette procédure à jl
aveugle et pourquoi privilégier la
taxation qui pèse plus lourd sur les
pauvres
il faut une réglementation choisi
démocratiquement jacqueline c'est pour
vous ça va directement c'est très simple
en fait le marché permis a été choisi au
niveau européen parce que pour mettre
une taxe en place au niveau européen il
faut l'unanimité des pays il n'y avait
pas du tout l'unanimité des pays pour
mettre en place une taxe tandis que pour
le marché de permis comme ça n'existait
pas au moment du traité de rome c'était
pas prévu en fait dans les traités
européens et donc une majorité des pays
pour accepter le la mise en place du
marché a suffi c'est juste une question
totalement institutionnelle en fait mais
du coup effectivement c'est ressenti
comme étant moins démocratique
merci bien d'autres questions la
question sur les accords commerciaux à
l'international on se demande s il
plombé pas les efforts consentis par
l'europe et la france sache peut-être en
dire un mot c'est vrai que les accords
commerciaux internationaux montrent
qu'ils sont c'est la prérogative de
l'europe de l'est de les négocier
souvent sont négociés par des gens qui
font du commerce et pas du tout par des
gens qui se préoccupent du climat donc
dans ces accords en fait jusqu'à
récemment au moins on s'intéressait pas
du tout à l'aspect climatique
donc voilà c'est tout à fait vrai qu'ils
prenaient pas ça en compte et en plus
les accords internationaux qui vise au
développement du commerce plus de
commerce ça veut dire plus de transport
international de marchandises transport
international de marchandises et très
émetteurs de carbone et de pay pal
carbone il est exempté en fait y'a pas
de taxes ni de rien aucun prix sur le
carbone émis par le transport
international de marchandises dont il ya
quelques idées autour de ça pour
empêcher
ça par exemple il y avait une idée qui
avait été émise qui est d'un veto
climatique que quand dans un accord
international de commerce il ya des
choses qui se passent qui sont en fait
dommageable pour le climat que le pays
la france par exemple qui s'en
offusquent que puisse mettre un veto
climatique pour bloquer les choses en
question quoi voilà mais c'est vrai que
on a on a négligé les aspects
environnementaux et climatiques dans les
accords de commerce jusqu'à maintenant
c'est exact merci beaucoup quand un
impôt supplémentaire là-dessus sur
l'histoire des accords pourquoi pas
aussi parfois le transformer en force
on sait que au niveau européen on n'a
pas le droit aujourd'hui de taxer
certains carburants parce qu'il est une
directive européenne qui nous en empêche
mais on a le droit si on se met d'accord
avec le pays de taxer les carburants de
l'avion dans les deux pays donc il est
ses possibilités et surtout je voulais
réagir à la question qu'on a un peu
évacués sur les les normes d'émission et
le fait que les constructeurs ont un peu
triché et voilà il ya eu d el gheït très
clairement je voulais juste préciser qu'
il ya des nouvelles des nouveaux tests
qui ont été mis en place par l'europe et
qui sont appliquées en france dès cette
année voilà donc c'est ce sera plus
possible de tricher comme avant en tout
cas il ya des nouvelles normes wtp qui
sont plus proches des conditions réelles
merci beaucoup
encore une question j'en ai même trois
si on peut attendre le groupe voilà est
ce que est ce que mathilde et aux
pierres et mohamed arrive pas à se
dépêtrer de leurs 150 questions
normalement ils doivent venir nous en
apporter quelques unes
il y avait une question aussi sur le sur
des présentations qui ont été faites
tout à l'heure est-ce qu'elle tenait
bien compte de tous les territoires
français avec une remarque sur le fait
que la nouvelle calédonie était absente
du protocole de kyoto et de l'accord de
paris donc on se demandait si c'était le
cas la nouvelle calédonie absente du
protocole de kyoto et des accords de
paris quelque chose à dire là dessus il
vous semble que non est-ce que vous
pouvez la fin peut-être la meilleure
spécialiste des accords de paris étant
avec nous j'ai pas complètement bien
compris la question est ce qu'on peut me
l'a répété qu' est-ce que oui absolument
oui on a assez la france est au sens
large y compris la guyane pour ça que
d'ailleurs la déforestation en guyane où
les mines sont compliquées ces prix en
est là venez pierre en attendant j'ai
deux questions
venez avec avec sophie une question sur
comment éviter que la guyane oui mais la
nouvelle calédonie pardon qui parle la
bière avant de parler il faut demander
si vous la leur alors allez-y puisque
vous avez la marolle la guyane oui mais
la nouvelle calédonie et la palène
statut alors été comptés dans les
émissions françaises
au fédéral la différence de statut entre
la guyane la réunion de tout aux dires
des statuts différents
mais pour prendre en compte les
émissions et donc toute une longue
discussion entre la france et l'europe
les émissions dede de tous ces
départements territoire ou autres
d'outre-mer ont été inclus dans les
émissions françaises
hop hop on fait lituanie cran
est ce que tu sais si tu descends si tu
descend d'un cran tu trouveras un micro
je pense ou de deux grands alors en
attendant tu alors mesdames messieurs
vous allez assister au fait qu'on est
sur une question complexe
comme vous pouvez le constater et du
coup on n'est pas toujours sûr et proulx
pas toujours d'accord
coop fédérée ce père qui travaille à la
dgec
notre direction générale de 2 l'an de
l'énergie et du climat pardon la
nouvelle calédonie effectivement un
statut très particulier qui comptait
dans les éditions françaises prêtent une
part c'est une part très faible des
émissions par rapport aux émissions
bleus delà de la france métropolitaine
donc c'est un sujet statutairement
important mais en termes de volume
d'émissions s'est pas assez pas non plus
n'en reste aurait des émissions
françaises
l'engagement de mémoire est là elle est
allée partie patron de la coop paris
mais elle n'est pas dans l'engagement de
l'union européenne ya un engagement
spécifique il me semble de la nouvelle
calédonie ou effectuant par son statut
là la nouvelle kenny perry et dans la
france mais elle n'est pas dans l'union
européenne ne me trompe pas et donc elle
n'est pas dans l'engagement de l'ue en
peine et donc de la france à la coop
mais par contre je crois qu'elle a un
engagement prob en rappelant celle là
les institutions font c'est assez
compliqué même que le gouvernement
français n'est pas compétent sur ce
sujet on sait le gouvernement de
nouvelle calédonie qui qu'il est pour
exprimer ce qu'il souhaite alors si je
propose qu'on arrête alors attends là
que j'ai encore une question c'est
peut-être dommage qu'on coupait pied
ensuite on en sort de rome fini tout
individuel c'était un peu particulier
avait oublié de rendre leur fiche
donc ils en ont aiguillé une enfin deux
j'en prend qu'une quelle est l'influencé
des lobbys est ce qu'on peut avoir des
exemples concrets de d'intervention
d'acteurs concrets dans les questions
qu'on aborde salaire de vous mettre en
joie
jean-marc j'adore les lobbys en fait
quand on pense lobby dans le français
courant on pense lobby industriel mais
lobby c'est n'importe quel groupe qui
défend un intérêt dont greenpeace et un
lobby exactement comme l'union des
industries chimiques est un lobby
d'accord alors qu elle l influence des
lobbys elle est extrêmement forte
parce que dans les démocraties les
gouvernements n'ont jamais le temps de
regarder le fond technique des dossiers
avant de prendre des décisions
c'est une impossibilité matérielle
d'accord ils n'ont juste pas le temps
est donc très très souvent ça fait 18
ans que je fréquente la vie politique de
l'extérieur discutant avec des ministres
et des députés divers la façon dont ça
fonctionne c'est que il ya une prime
très forte à celui qui a un instant
donné on respecte le plus fort mais les
gilets jaunes c'était un lobby du reste
qui s'est auto construits en temps réel
donc en fait sont des lobbys tous les
gens qui
chercher à influer la politique publique
au sens large et leur influence est
extrêmement forte et extrêmement mais
encore une fois pas que les industriels
d'une manière générale tous les groupes
de pression et cgt tout ça c'est des
lobbys ça cherche à influer la façon
dont on structure la politique publique
ce qui veut dire qu'une des manières de
faire progresser le débat dans ce genre
de sujet
c'est d'essayer à parler d'eux à
l'intérieur de tous ces lobbys parce que
au moment où ils prennent position les
jeux sont faits on arrive après la
bataille est donc les débats doivent
avoir lieu au sein de ses instances la
donc le j'ai envie de retourner la
question en disant tous les gens qui
sont intéressés par cette question et
qui le seront je l'espère encore plus
dans quelques semaines et bien je vous
invite à aller porter le débat dans
toutes les instances auxquelles vous
pouvez appartenir de l'intérieur parce
que c'est là qu'il faut prendre le temps
d'en discuter et de prendre du recul sur
les choses
voilà de fait les corps constitués sont
des facteurs de pression très fort c'est
un peu moins vrai à l'europe que dans
l'égout dans les pays pris
individuellement les députés européens
sont un peu plus j'aimerais dire un peu
plus loin des pressions des politiques
nationales
ils ont un peu plus de tension un peu
moins sous les projecteurs donc c'est
globalement un peu moins vrai mais voilà
mais effectivement c'est qu'elle séduit
une vraie réalité mais ça s'applique à
plein d'organismes
merci beaucoup alors je propose que nous
passions maintenant aux questions que
vous avez élaboré un petit groupe et
pierre qui a participé à l'organisation
de ces différentes questions va nous les
nous les présenter les unes après les
autres
peut-être pas les 150 d'un coup on est
d'accord et pendant ce temps là julien
va continuer de les inscrire sur sur la
feuille
enfin plus exactement à l'écran
je mets les messieurs il est 18h21 et
quoi qu'il arrive nous nous arrêterons à
19h00 sur cette séquence parce que nous
avons d'autres choses à faire et
d'autres sujets à voir et puis parce qu
il sera tard ce qui veut dire qu'il ya
des questions auxquelles nous ne
pourrons pas apporté de réponse cet
après midi nous ferons comme pour les
précédentes évidemment nous ne perdons
rien ici rien ne se perd tout se
transforme et donc toutes ces questions
se transformeront en réponse sous des
formes que l'on va regarder ensemble et
notamment avec le comité de gouvernance
parce que vous imaginez bien que 150
questions ça va demander un travail
relativement importante donc il faut
qu'on trouve le moyen le plus pratique
pour vous et le plus praticable pour
nous d'apporter les réponses mais de
toute façon vous les apportera dans les
plus brefs délais pierre la première
question s'il vous plaît alors avec
mohamed mathilde et léo nous avons
essayé de trier vos questions qui était
intéressante en fonction des items que
nous allons développer à partir de
demain donc le logement se déplacer la
fiscalité etc
l'économie bien sûr mes collaborateurs
la continua à dépouiller les questions
alors je vais commencer par le logement
pourquoi y at il des quotas qui limitent
l'autonomie énergétique des habitations
roy y at il des quotas qui limitent
c'est comme ça qu'on nous a c'est comme
ça je crois que c'est une question par
rapport à la limitation des puissances
qu'on peut avoir en autoconsommation et
électrique je suis coincé n'étant pas le
meilleur expert de la direction sur ce
sujet pointu propose effectivement on a
on apporte des réponses
sachant qu'on acclame développer un
certain nombre de deux systèmes dont les
compteurs intelligents qui permettent à
la fois d'auto de consommer sa propre
électricité et de l'injecter quand ans
quand on en a trop et il ya effet quand
je crois eu une limite technique qui
peut qui est peut-être à revoir mais je
serai pas vous en dire oui mais c'est
beaucoup plus globale la question
elle va aussi au social et elle va aussi
à ce qu'a dit le jeune homme là c'est
l'auto l'autonomie d'une maison
énergétiquement parlant même pour celui
qui n'a pas d'argent c'est possible
simplement il ya des limitations de
production qui induisent le fait qu on
plonge pas parce que finalement on doit
toujours payer alors que si les
limitations était bien au delà c'est à
dire s'il y avait aucune limitation est
bien dans la production d'électricité
serait compris le prix des panneaux le
prix de l'installation
le prix de l'énergie que consomme la
maison et son isolation sa rénovation
énergétique tout ça si c'était
globalement possible moi ça fait 20 ans
que je serai à ce moment-là producteur
d'électricité
ça fait vingt ans que ça fait mon
troisième de villa depuis la nouvelle
norme de 2018 et ça c'est un exemple
très concret de l'eau du ddt du dans la
population il ya une sorte de 2 comment
de fatalisme que ce qu'ils disent
finalement on nous demande d'être
écologique mais on en use an permet aux
moi je veux pas gagner de l'argent avec
la production mais je veux que ma maison
soit autonome et dans l'est dans les
territoires
rue urbain dans mon village par exemple
je suis certain chaos - plus de la
moitié des maisons anciennes moi j'ai
une très vieille maison mais je l'ait
déjà restauré mais on serait énorme
énormément de personnes à être
écologiquement je ne consommerai plus
une seule goutte de fioul si on me
laissait bâloise on a compris on a
compris point jean marc jancovici
je veux juste faire une remarque sur le
l'objet du débat il se trouve qu'en
france
utiliser de l'énergie solaire plutôt que
l'énergie de réseau surtout si on a une
batterie derrière ne fait rien gagné sur
les émissions donc c'est un débat qui
est hors climat s'était juste ça que je
voulais faire remarquer
c'est au climat
je vous assure alors après ce que je
peux rajouter aussi puisque je vous vois
un peu étonné c'est qu'il ya une
confusion dans le discours public depuis
très très longtemps entre le sujet
nucléaire et le sujet climat donc entre
le sujet électrique et le sujet climat
et de cette confusion n'est le fait que
beaucoup de gens pensent que alors il ya
de trucs beaucoup de gens pensent le
premier c'est que le nucléaire
contribuer significativement aux
émissions de gaz à effet de serre il a
plein de défauts peut-être mais c'est
pas celui-là c'est physiquement pas
possible et du coup il ya dans le
discours médiatique qui du coup aussi
très confus l'idée que par exemple
l'autoconsommation est quelque chose qui
est un bon geste pour le climat alors
encore une fois ça peut avoir des tas
d'autres fondements mais malheureusement
celui là non c'est un débat qui est hors
climat merci beaucoup aux pierres une
autre question si possible dans un autre
groupe thématique très bien un sujet qui
brûle en la fiscalité
l'économie qu'est ce qui bloque pour
donner un prix plus élevé aux ressources
naturelles
quels sont les freins au fait que les
ressources naturelles n'est pas le leur
lors leurs prix finalement peut-être un
peu plus en adéquation avec alors on va
demander à une pure économistes si vous
pré permettez cette ce qualificatif et
puis quand un aussi vous dire à un mot à
ce sujet allez-y kathleen ce qui bloque
si elle est bien proche je pense que ce
qui bloque c'est qu'il ya quand même de
façon générale une réticence à rajouter
des impôts donc rajouter des impôts
encore sur les ressources naturelles sur
le carbone et compagnie bon ça c'est une
partie quand même importante donc je
pense qu'on se dit on devrait pouvoir y
arriver autrement sans alourdir la
fiscalité
donc c'est pour ça que ce que dirait ce
que femme moi ce que j'aurais tendance à
dire c'est que si on si on fait payer
davantage de ressources naturelles en
mettant des impôts ou le carbone il faut
rendre cet argent d'une façon ou d'une
autre aux gens c'est ce que j'essayais
de dire tout à l'heure il faut pas que
ce soit une un alourdissement de la
fiscalité il faut que ce soit simplement
une façon de faire payer un vrai service
qui soit rendue aux gens si possible en
fonction de leurs revenus pour que ce
soit fait de façon juste ou leur
localisation géographique ou de leurs
équipements etc
voilà donc c'est je pense qu'en fait ce
qui bloque c'est un manque de
transparence qui ont eu les
gouvernements peut-être et
d'explications et de bon alors kathleen
est ce que est ce que vous pouvez re
dire la même chose mais peut-être de
façon différente parce que
la dame la vindicte personnelle je crois
les autres mais j'ai pas compris la
question 1 à la populace question pour
donner un prix plus plus un prix plus
élevé aux ressources naturelles qui sait
ça veut dire j'ai peut-être vais t'en
mets pas du tout je ne parle pas du tout
pas du tout quel est le groupe qui a
inventé sa création c'est là qu'ils y à
la parole vous avez 20 secondes pour
vous justifier
cg de la haute-vienne ça va être très
rapide en fait les ressources naturelles
sont gratuites
et donc la question que je voulais poser
c'est quel prix vous pouvez donner à ces
ressources naturelles pour que tout le
monde dans le monde met notamment en
france puisse avoir le vrai prix du
produit qu'on achète
et pas simplement sur coup deux
transformations alors là j'ai
l'impression que c'est une question
d'économie fondamentale non maintenant
mais je crois que la réponse je refais
la même raison c'est ce que je fais la
même réponse c'est qu'en effet il
faudrait leur donner un prix parce que
certaines d'entre elles n'ont pas de
prix de marché donc il faudrait celles
qui n'ont pas de prix de marché au moins
il faudrait leur donner un prix mais
sauf qu'on n'y arrive pas parce que on
s'y prend pas bien aux réalités on s'y
prend pas bien on n'aime pas les agneaux
compléter rapidement ses on a parlé tout
à l'heure de taxes a rajouté je dis
simplement que c'est pas une taxe qu'on
rajoute c'est une valeur qu'on donne à
la base aux produits et cette taxe à la
fin la taxe carbone que vous voulez
rajouter ça c'est une taxe mais là c'est
devenu une valeur aux produits naturels
j'ai autre chose alors jean matérialisme
prigent là j'entends archi jean marc
jancovici veulent donner un exemple je
vais je vais vous donner un exemple à
partir de la maison de thomas pesquet me
connaissaient de thomas pesquet alors
oui la maison en eau et sel sa maison de
vacances la salle où il va de temps en
temps alors thomas pesquet la tangente
en vacances dans l'espace
est ce que vous savez combien coûte la
station spatiale internationale elle
coûte 100 milliards de dollars d'accords
100 milliards de dollars
est ce que vous savez c'est alors c'est
un f je pars combien on tient à 6 donc
ça veut dire que la station spatiale
internationale vo 15 milliards de
dollars par personne
vous êtes d'accord à quoi il sert la
station spatiale internationale srs que
dans un endroit où vous pouvez pas
respirer où il fait très froid parce que
là où il est institué s'est fait très
froid ou non on puisse au moins respirer
et ne pas mourir de froid
d'accord c'est les deux choses
auxquelles ça sert ça sert aussi à
recycler l'eau et ne vous dit pas d'où
elle vient évidemment
donc ça sert à juste trois choses alors
vous dites la planète terre elle fait
tout ça pour nous elle nous a donné une
atmosphère qu'on peut respirer il fait
ni trop chaud ni trop froid enfin fort
un petit pull en ce moment mais
globalement ni trop chaud donc on peut
dire que la planète terre vaut au moins
15 milliards de dollars par personne
- d'accord la planète terre aujourd'hui
on en mange au moins un pour mille par
an d'accord on diminue les stocks de
poissons diminuent le stock de pétrole
on met du co2 dans l'atmosphère on
diminue les stocks de forêt quand vous
regardez il ya au moins un pour mille de
la planète qu'on mange chaque année
alors un pour mille de 15 milliards
c'est 15 millions d'accord donc le vrai
coût de la nature moi je vous le chiffre
au moins à 15 millions par an et par
personne
il faut savoir qu'en moyenne mondiale la
production économique ce n'est pas 15
millions ces 15 mille dollars par an et
par personne donc le vrai coût de la
nature c'est peut-être au moins mille
fois ce qu'on gagne donc ya pas de
réponse économique c'est là que je
voulais en venir avec cet exemple il ya
malheureusement pas de réponse
économique à ce problème et il ya
quelqu'un qui m'a dit un jour on
n'arrivera jamais à résoudre le problème
du changement climatique en rentrant par
l'économie ça doit devenir un problème
éthique
dit autrement on doit se dire on n'en
veut pas et à ce moment on adapte
l'économie et si l'économie doit nous
offrir un peu moins il ya un peu moins
de bombes de laque et de vêtements ont
fait avec parce que le bénéfice est
tellement important à nos yeux qu'on a
envie de le faire mais il y aura jamais
l'économie ne pourra jamais être autre
chose qu'un instrument pour l'action et
jamais un instrument de justification
voilà c'était ça que je voulais dire
jean marc jancovici nous emmène dans les
étoiles
[Musique]
troisième question bière alors l'item se
déplacer à l'est est ce que les normes
évoqué par madame schubert comme
éventuellement dangereuse par rapport au
prix d'achat final
par exemple pour une voiture ne serait
pas au final un tremplin une incitation
à l'innovation donnant une
démocratisation de technologies plus
propres
c'est un peu complexe question jeu là on
la lui on s'est concerté on a décidé de
la laisser tel quel et et parce que on
avait du mal à l'arrêt reformuler on va
dire je pense que oui c'est vrai que les
normes peuvent inciter à produire des
technologies plus propres ça tout à fait
j'ai pas dit le contraire d'ailleurs je
pense que c'est exact
simplement on peut obtenir aussi des
incitations à faire des technologies
plus propres par la taxe pourquoi parce
que la taxe ça donne un business model
disant aux activités propres parce que
sans elle
tant que les activités à base de faux
cils sont pas chères y a pas vraiment
d'incitation à produire des biens
propres et des biens vers donc la norme
ça peut donner une incitation à des
innovations vertes la taxe aussi voilà
merci
excusez moi juste une cadre en fait moi
ce que j'entends dans la question
le sait aussi qu ia l'existant et
l'existant il n'est pas satisfaisant
pour réduire les émissions de carbone
alors pourquoi ne pas pousser la
recherche et l'innovation
ça c'est de l'ordre de l'état pour
pouvoir justement promouvoir qu'on
parlait tout à l'heure des batteries
lithium des choses comme ça je suis sûr
qu'il ya beaucoup de chercheurs des
experts pour le coup qu'on n'est pas
qu'ils pourraient eux promouvoir leur
savoir et leur technicité pour trouver
des solutions concrètes et est du coup
c'est de l'ordre de l'état de promouvoir
ce genre de recherche
laurent michel entièrement d'accord pas
pardonné alors oui mais alors il sauve
moi comme quand j'étais jeune
fonctionnaire j'ai commencé par faire de
la réglementation dont d'enfin
l'appliquer
et donc moi j'aime bien trouver un outil
est effectivement de donner un signal de
lire dans dix ans on est comme ça ça
donne un horizon pour développer une
technologie une organisation un
programme d'actions et selon les moments
combinée avec une taxe ou un texte
ça donne le chemin il ya besoin d'en si
c'était si simple
effectivement que vous dites on le repaf
on aurait besoin de rien c'est vrai il
ya souvent besoin de développer des
systèmes voir des technologies alors et
sans dire je vais surtout pas dire que
que c'est pas refaire je suis pas là
pour ça mais dire qu'il y à ossun de
l'état depuis plusieurs années ça ça a
traversé plusieurs majorités on va dire
des programmes dits par un programme
d'investissements d'avenir qui
travaillent sur le qui apporte très en
amont plutôt concept des projets publics
de la bagarre ou un peu plus en aval
myst laboratoires publics et entreprises
pour développer des nouvelles
technologies et ensuite il faut
évidemment ensuite passer à
l'industrialisation
c'est pas la peine d'avoir dans son coin
le camion super génial mais qu'on
n'arrive jamais en vendre et c'est donc
ça peut être ai je ne dis pas que c'est
simple que tout va se résoudre par magie
mais évidemment des questions de
politique industrielle et même plus
globalement d'organisation si on parle
de la rénovation énergétique des
logements ou des bâtiments si vous dites
2030 les collectivités tel est l'état
tel niveau de performance est ce qu'on
arrive à avoir un poids une offre et une
demande qui est la technique et la
formation des entreprises tout pour pour
rénover et ça a quand même été 100 m s
attend ça a été quand même un des axes
que moi j'ai vu depuis quelques années
un accent mis en france et au niveau de
l'europe sur l'innovation pour les
technologies global pour l'organisation
plus propre en carbone en polluants
voire je m'appelle l'éco-conception des
produits qui génèrent moins de déchets
probablement faut-il encore aller
plus loin plus vite et il n'a raté
aucune étape c'est pas la peine d'avoir
en labo si on n'avait pas le faire en
vrai merci beaucoup je demande à mes
camarades de tribunes de bien vouloir
faire des réponses un chouïa plus courte
de façon à ce qu'on puisse passer plus
de question de la guerre je peux prendre
la parole ici demi on parle de taxes
depuis tout à l'heure mais il est une
chose une minute
oui une minute on parle de taxes depuis
de telles armes on oublie une chose
c'est que là on est censé voir pour le
climat mais aussi le social est en fait
ça passera pas par des taxes les gilet
jaune ça devient mondiale donc il faut
arrêter de réfléchir en forme de taxes
pour toujours les mêmes personnes
il me semble que ya les caf raconta
cache pas donc là il n'y a pas d'argent
à prendre y alliez sf
il ya d'autres solutions faut arrêter de
toujours taxer les gens
vous le dire un mot là-dessus canton je
voudrais ajouter quelque chose lancé
yolande où il reste juste à vous dire
quelque chose
il ya aussi 500 niches fiscales qui
représentent 100 milliards d'euros ça
sent niches fiscales enfin je crois que
ça a baissé un petit peu mais je crois
qu'il ya eu une dizaine vingtaine de
supprimer la mais voilà il y en a de
l'argent on a d'argent
effectivement la lutte contre les
fraudes fils la fraude fiscale google
amazon etc
il faut aller le chercher l'argent faut
du courage politique avant tout quentin
que kathleen et quentin deux mots
là-dessus juste dire un petit mot bon
moi je crois au pollueur payeur quoi
fondamentalement donc bah oui va les
plus grosses entreprises qui polluent le
mans sur cette reprise des entreprises
et les ménages pareil je crois pollueur
payeur je pense juste qu'il faut rendre
les choses justes c'est à dire que cet
argent il faut le rendre aux gens qui
sont vulnérables et qui sont dans la
difficulté pour changer leur
comportement alors un mot un mode un
mode réponse à l'aise il dit ce que vous
voulez dire
jeudi les gens ils sont dans la
difficulté à l'heure actuelle y en a qui
mangent pas ou très peu donc et sont
obligés de prendre leur voiture pour
aller travailler
donc voilà et je pense qu'il ya d'autres
formes de taxes à prendre sur des gens
qui ont de l'argent voilà il ya plein de
gens qui sont dans la difficulté il y en
a aussi énormément qui ne sont pas les
gens qui achètent des gros suv qui roule
énormément ils peuvent faire un petit
banc alors là il faut diriger les taxes
versées gens là et quand on achète une
voiture ont fourni
son petit impôt et on sera taxée là
dessus alors quand un puits jean-marc
s'il vous plaît très court même exercice
est difficile mais c'est important
une réaction à deux questions il ya eu
donc la question de finalement il n'y a
pas que le climat est aussi sociale je
suis tout à fait d'accord et je
rajouterais ya même pas que le climat il
ya l'environnement de façon générale et
quand j'ai parlé du fait que par exemple
certaines villes interdisent les
véhicules diesel
c'est bon pour le climat mais c'est
aussi extrêmement bon pour les
particules fines parce qu'on sait qu'en
centre-ville il ya beaucoup trop de
particules fines et de penser à des
solutions qui sont bonnes pour le social
et pour la santé et bien vous allez on
peut avoir des propositions beaucoup
plus fortes qui vont dans le bon sens
donc je pense qu'il faut pas hésiter à
étendre un peu le spectre et sur la
question des niches fiscales
on a passé en revue le budget de l'état
et forcing je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous je dirais il ya même en
particulier 20 milliards de 16 milliards
de niches fiscales défavorables au
climat sert des taux réduits pour des
entreprises qui font qu'elles sont pas
trop inciter à réduire les émissions et
donc c'est là où peut-être des idées de
dd mais différemment et descend fournir
sans supprimer l'incitation aider
autrement qu'avec des taux réduits sur
les taxes aussi pour le dire autrement
et là il ya effectivement des recettes
possibles finalement ce que nous montre
aussi nos estimations des
investissements je le répète un mais
c'est 5 à 7 milliards par an qui manque
c'est pas tant que ça pour mettre en
perspective la taxe d'habitation ses 17
milliards g lui dans les décodeurs dont
8 milliards pour la part sur les 20% les
plus riches
vous voyez qu'on est dans des ordres de
grandeurs encore une fois qu'ils sont
pas excessifs
l'enjeu est difficile très difficile
mais les montants finalement sont pas si
exorbitant merci jean marc
oui moi je voudrais dire deux choses une
qui va vous plaire à une qui va pas vous
plaire la chose qui va pas vous plaire
c'est que aujourd'hui les émissions d'un
français moyen
alors évidemment les vôtres et celle de
bernard arnault sont pas les mêmes mais
les émissions d'un français moyen
ces dix tonnes équivalent co2 par an
d'ici à ce que vos enfants et votre âge
il faut que ça descende à 2 alors vous
comprenez que il faut assurément taper
sur les riches mais ça suffira pas
l'autre
donc tout le monde va devoir prendre sa
part à l'effort donc ça c'est la très
mauvaise nouvelle c'est que
malheureusement tout le monde va devoir
faire quelque chose là où je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec vous c'est que il
faut pas demander un effort si les gens
n'ont pas d'alternative
donc les taxes sur le tabac vous avez
une alternative qui est d'arrêter de
fumer
elle n'est pas facile elle n'est pas
facile mais vous avez une alternative
bon le voir les anciens fumeurs mais moi
j'en fais partie et parfumée longtemps
le lait donc quand chacun doit prendre
sa part à l'effort il pour appeler un
chat un chat de mettre les pieds dans le
plat ça veut dire qu'on va devoir gérer
une restriction c'est très clair c'est
très exactement ce dont il est question
le on a le choix de l'instrument donc
c'est ce qui a été expliqué derrière et
en fait c'est évident qu'il faut
combiner tout ça donc il faut dans le
même temps taxer à la chaire les
voitures pour éviter que les gens
achètent des grosses voitures parce que
les gilets jaunes
s'ils sont en position d'acheter une
voiture ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
fa temps en temps ils en achètent bien
d'une puisqu'ils en ont envie on peut
les mettre en position va acheter celles
qui consomment le moins possible et ça
continue à suffire quelque part pour
aller au boulot qui est un truc
absolument indispensable peut pas
demander à quelqu'un prononcé d'aller au
boulot au motif que l'essence est trop
chère
tout à fait d'accord avec vous donc le
don qu'il ya cette fiscalité là et il ya
également des mesures d'accompagnement
alors les mesures d'accompagnement on
peut aussi les choisir donc ya pas juste
le prélèvement il ya la mesure
d'accompagnement
d'ailleurs laurent michel parler du plan
vélo alors je vais très très agréable
avec lui le plan vélo aujourd'hui c'est
un km de pistes cyclables par
département et par an d'accord pour
comme disait l'autre je me marre et donc
voilà voilà avec l'accent donc c'est
donc on peut aussi choisir là où va
l'argent est là je suis parfaitement
d'accord avec une chose qui a été dit
tout à l'heure de l'argent et naples 1
simplement il va falloir qu'on choisisse
les pistes cyclables ou les ronds-points
ou la 5g ou je sais pas quoi donc il va
falloir qu'on se mette d'accord entre
nous et qu'on dise on fait des choix
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure on
est vraiment à l'heure des choix
mais ce choix l'heure des choix n'exclut
pas le fait que malheureusement tout le
monde va devoir prendre sa part à
l'effort c'est pour ça qu'au sein du
haut conseil en a parlé de justice la
justice c'est que l'effort soit perçue
comme légitime par l'essentiel de la
population je dis bien légitime alors
à ce moment-là perf et 10 secondes 10
secondes de parole à la défense parce
que dans mon oreille j'ai entendu mais
non mais non à propos du plan vélo donc
la parole à laurent michel lamesch même
malheureusement j'ai passé révisé pour
savoir combien c'est être km de pistes
cyclables par département mais de
mémoire c'est 150 initiative de
collectivités locales oddo dernière
appel à projets de l'état et un premier
soutien à hauteur de 35 9 euros et ça va
continuer j'ai pas dit que c'était
suffisant je ne dirai et je n'ai pas du
tout mais je dirais effectivement que là
on a bien vu les les débats les est
devant elle au bon endroit bien si
l'état c'est quelque chose qui à rentrer
sur les aides à la rénovation dis pas
que ce n'est parfait mais les taux des
dettes sont plus élevés pour les ménages
modestes grâce à l' agence nationale de
l'amélioration de l'habitat dans l'idée
que à la fois on est bon pour le climat
mais aussi couru pour économiser de la
facture énergétique parce que vous allez
souvent ce qu'on peut appeler la double
ou la triple peine
votre jugement et mal isolés pour la
santé c'est parfois pas très bon côté
humidité et compagnie et grosse
consommation et dirais moi objectivement
ce jeu pourrait investir si j'avais un
problème d'isolation
on sait qu'il ya pour beaucoup de
ménages et pas que les 10% les plus
pauvres
c'est un gros investissement même après
on peut vous expliquer où elles vendent
en disant vous allez être remboursé tous
les cement et parfois telle qu'il faut
intervenir donc où il faut arriver à
doser que ça faut pas que ça coûte
l'infini et may hamm en effectuant
mettre le paquet et en particulier une
différenciation pour permettre à ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin de passer à
l'acte sans difficulté majeure c'est
nécessaire dans l'accompagnement merci
beaucoup
alors mohamed nous a rejoint donc ça
veut dire qu'ils ont fini trier les 150
questions
waouh non un autre dit il mais en tout
cas vous avez de nouvelles questions il
est il nous reste un quart d'heure tout
pile
on essaye de faire au moins cinq
questions dans ce quart d'heure allez-y
bonjour mon c'est chalon mohamed vient
de la ville du mans selon la synthèse
que nous avons fait
nous avons des questions très
pertinentes
la première pourquoi égaliser le droit à
polluer
pourquoi ne pas taxer plus l'achat de
gros suv
alors qui veut répondre à ça
jean-marc sur la première latte sur la
deuxième là vous battez pas pour la
deuxième
alors quand un sur la deuxième et et sur
la première aussi fournir une réponse
alors effectivement vous avez sans doute
entendu parler du fait que les ventes de
suv augmente en france et même au niveau
mondial je crois que c'est au niveau
international je crois que les ventes
sont passées de 20 pour cent des ventes
de véhicules à 40 % en l'espace de dix
ans c'est énorme mais véhicules plus
gros plus polluants et forcément ça pose
la question du juste niveau de taxes on
a un niveau un objectif européen de 4 de
taxer à 4 devises et 95 g de co2 par
kilomètre pour les véhicules l'année
prochaine et on a un bonus malus qui lui
ne taxe que les véhicules au delà de 110
grammes de co2 par kilomètre vous voyez
que on a des objectifs nationaux qui
sont pas tout à fait raccord avec les
objectifs européens et je pense
qu'effectivement il ya une vraie
réflexion à avoir sur taxer plus les suv
qui sont pour partie des véhicules utile
pour les familles mais pour partie aussi
des véhicules où on se fait plaisir et
donc là pourquoi pas payer d'autant plus
le prix pour ça et je profite d'avoir la
parole pour juste définir un peu la taxe
carbone parce que je me rends compte
qu'on a énormément parlé de taxe carbone
sans peut-être vraiment définir de quoi
on parlait et je pense qu'on aurait dû
le faire plus tôt la taxe carbone juste
pour être au clair c'est une petite
partie de ce que vous payez sur les
taxes carburant ces 10 centimes d'euros
par litre sur l'essence après vous avez
80 autres centimes d'euros par litre
d'autres taxes et puis après vous avez
le prix d'extraction de l'essence et ses
nouvelles la taxe carbone c'est 6 % des
taxes sur les carburants pour un ménage
normal c'est vraiment c'est pas si gros
si vous regardez au niveau national
ça représente 8 milliards de recettes de
taxe carbone sur plus de 600 milliards
de recettes prélevées par l'état et
c'est pour ça que j'ai commencé mon
introduction en disant penser la
fiscalité dans son ensemble penser à ses
plus de 600 milliards pensez pas juste
aux 8 milliards en fait on parle que de
ça mais il faut pas se perdre dans la
goutte d'eau non plus merci alors
j'essaye d'équilibré entre les questions
collectives des questions individuelles
c'est pour ça que je vous donne pas
toujours la parole
la première question en fait c'était pas
pourquoi égaliser mais pourquoi
légaliser le droit à polluer à ça c'est
beaucoup plus clair
alors ça il peut répondre oui très bien
j'ai ce qu'on a historiquement appelé
les droits à polluer en fait c'étaient
les quotas d'émission de co2 alors en
fait un quota d'émissions c'est une
autorisation administrative d'émettre un
visa qui par ailleurs est échangeable
c'est sûr si vous vous en servez pas
pouvez la vendre à quelqu'un d'autre
dont l'activité fait qu'il va émettre
plus que l'autorisation qu'on lui a
donné c'est ça hein
donc en fait dès que vous avez une
autorisation administrative par
construction vous avez quelque chose qui
est légal une autorisation
administrative c'est par construction
dont on appelle légaliser des droits à
polluer
on a instauré des autorisations
administratives des maîtres mais dont le
principe initial était que ça allait
justement être en quantité limitée c'est
à dire qu'on allait pas vous autoriser à
émettre autant vous voulez on allait
justement vous coller une contrainte en
volume en dix ans chaque année ou plus
jacques par période de plusieurs années
on va vous autorisez de moins en moins
alors ça c'est la théorie après il ya
des tas de trucs qui font qu en pratique
ça marche plus ou moins bien mais la
théorie elle est là donc dans la théorie
c'est légal d'entrée de jeu merci
beaucoup monsieur vous souhaitiez
intervenir je donne la parole une
seconde et demie dans ma grande
générosité
je suis guillaume de bordeaux donc
parler de taxe carbone taxe carbone si
bien si vous si j'aime bien mais on a
déjà des la tva qui est là pour la taxe
valeur ajoutée 1
pourquoi la ferai pas évoluer en
fonction de l'impact carbone sur les
produits que l'on achète soit diminuer
la tva la passer à 10 ou la passer à 25
à 30 voire 33 ans je vous rappelle il ya
longtemps on avait la tva de luxe ont
rappelé à 33%
et moi je pense que ça serait nettement
plus juste que d'instaurer encore une
taxe supplémentaire alors qu'on a déjà
des leviers financiers est obligatoire
au niveau
nos instances et du ministère des
finances soit donc quelque part je
trouve que le débat il est un petit peu
déplacé fait que cette taxe carbone à ce
qu'on tourne toujours autour du suv moi
j'en ai suivi il consomme 4 les 201
donc il y en a un petit peu marre des
suv
par contre une bagnole à 45000 euros un
suv avec un v8 qui fait 15 les 300 ben
on n'a qu'à le taxer à 33 % voire 40% de
plus dans kathleen un mot là-dessus
michelle wie laurent pardon parce que je
pense que le à la base c'est parce que
on a envie de taxer ce qui pollue ceux
qui polluent c'est bien le carbone donc
c'est quand même beaucoup plus directe
la taxe carbone que de passer par la tva
donc et beaucoup plus transparent aussi
parce que passer par la tva ça
embrouille vraiment le faire on veut
taxer le carbone taxe carbone vient
j'eus eu du monde du transmanche
formatant d'un métier de transport donc
de toutes façons le produit vous avez
dans grandes surfaces ou n'importe où il
est transporté donc circuits courts
moins de taxes circuits longs gros
stacks laurent michel s'il vous plaît
violence violence juste une seconde deux
secondes deux secondes vraiment certes
le gasoil des voitures polluent mais
alors le kérosène et les bateaux de
croisière et les yachts parlons sens
parce que ça aussi c'est beaucoup
d'émissions
alors là absolument est entièrement
d'accord avec vous il n'y a aucune
raison
vous n'avez pas paris ni théorie parce
qu'on les taxe pas ça c'est vraiment une
mesure fondamentale après android et met
en vedette le chiffre donné par l'un
d'entre vous 600 milliards de recettes
de l'état dans 600 milliards n'y a pas
que les recettes de l'état alors
oui j'ai peut-être fourché ça dépend si
vous pensez en brut où en est cette
histoire de remboursement 3 plutôt 3 400
milliards en effectif il ya les
remboursements après qu'ils sont faits
chst alors donc laurent michel dit un
mot en réponse à guillaume à lui puis
jean-marc rapidement oui et ensuite lors
face sur d'abord à venir dont la taxe
taxer ce qui pollue versus ce qui pollue
pas est un des leviers n'était pas le
seul s'il prend les la tva pourrait être
un moyen de différenciation
théoriquement si on arrivait à
identifier facilement des catégories qui
d'objets qui émettent pour le même usage
moins de carbone
s'il se trouve que sur les célèbres suv
en fait ce qui existe aujourd'hui en
france et dans un certain nombre de pays
pas tous c'est ce qu'on appelle le malus
or le bonus aides à l'achat de véhicules
propres
le malus taxe de manière croissante
c'est au début ces petits puis après ça
monte ça monte ça monte en fonction des
du test des missions les grammes de co2
par km est donc en fait c'est pas taxer
ce n'est pas l'objet et suivez ce n'est
de suv qui ont le même look mais y en a
un qui consomme 4 litres au cent et
l'autre 8 litres aux cents à huit cents
là vous serez en loi de finances
si elle est votée telle quelle à 2500
euros de taxes 7 l'année prochaine ce
que là pour le coup
à mon avis ne fera pas vraiment les
personnes les plus modestes qui aurait
les moyens de s'acheter ses gros
véhicules les plus lointains donc d'une
manne sait on rentre là il se trouve que
la tva vous évoquez a est utilisé
je sais pas si c'est le meilleur outil
ou pas mais est utilisé à contrario il
ya une tva à taux réduit pour les
travaux de rénovation des logements
génère iti la tva de base sur le
bâtiment c'est 10% fait de la rénovation
énergétique l'illustrateur il ya
plusieurs années a dit que c'était cinq
et demi pour cent donc on utilise là
c'est pas pour taxer ce qui pollue
c'est pour accompagner ceux qui font un
effort
donc on est seize législateur ça
ressemble gouvernement parlement et tous
les gens qui s'expriment de trouver des
outils adéquats y compris de baisses de
taxes un parement ça va être la baisse
de taxes merci l'europe justement pour
rester sur les taxes il y a aussi des
économistes qui préconise eu de taxer
les énergies primaires
ce qui fait que ça aura un impact sur
toute la filière de production jusqu'à
la consommation de reversés en totalité
la taxe prélevée sur la population et en
partant du principe que le citoyen est
suffisamment intelligent pour comprendre
que ce qui coûte plus cher lui permettra
pas de pouvoir mieux vivre donc en fait
l'argent qu'on lui reverse s'il veut
vraiment profiter faut qu'il aille vers
quelque chose qui est décarbonée
et là pour le coup on inverse le système
de consommation rétabli une justice
sociale c'est à dire que ce qui est payé
sur les énergies primaires carbonées et
reversé totalement aux citoyens qui aura
justement l'intelligence par exemple
entre une tomate élevé en serre avec
chauffent au fioul
une tomate en plein air au soleil mais
forcément celle en plein air au soleil
coûtera moins cher il ira vers ce qui
est meilleur pour la nature je voudrais
savoir si cet aspect là a été également
étudié dans la taxation et dans la
redistribution sociale et je vous
demande de faire une réponse en moins de
dix secondes parce qu'il est moins 5 et
que je veux qu'on fasse au moins une
autre question je suis désolé mais je
deviens radical ça veut dire taxer à la
source
taxé à la sortie de la raffinerie en
fait c'est graffiteurs qui paye
c'est une bonne idée simplement le
raffineur va répercuter dans les prix
au final ça va faire augmenter le prix
de l'essence pareil donc c'est une très
bonne idée
on peut faire ça on pourrait faire ça
récupérer l'argent est reversé aux
ménages mais il faut bien voir que les
ménages paieront quand même au final le
prix parce que ça sera répercutée mais
on peut notamment y lire on verse que
mosher donc ce qui est pas car bonne et
ça c'est bien sûr ce n'est non merci
une autre question pierre où ce sera moi
même mais en fait on va changer on
parlera plus de taxes là maintenant oui
change de c'est bien c'est une bonne
idée changeant et items démographie on a
mis elle est mauvaise l'objectif de -40%
qu en est il de la démographie de notre
pays
c'est à dire en fait est-ce que
l'augmentation de la démographie du pays
est prise en compte dans la réduction
des gaz à effet de serre alors on sera
bientôt 70 de de réponse en 30 secondes
laurent puissante marque s'est inscrit
dans la loi et pas d'engagement européen
c'est la france en tant que france que
sa population croise ou pas voilà donc
et si vous avez un taux de croissance de
population de 3 % versus 1%
effectivement l'effort par individu nous
notre collectif est plus dur à faire
mais effectivement tous ces chiffres que
je vous ai présenté ou ceux qui sont
dans les lois autres sont l'entité
global france que sa population croit ce
que vous touchez du doigt là un problème
qui pour moi est à la fois très
douloureux est primordial il est
douloureux parce que le fait d'avoir des
enfants c'est un truc qui touche à nos
tripes mais il faut bien voir je sais
pas si ça vous a été dit par valérie
masson quand elle est venue ici que le
point important avec le changement
climatique c'est la quantité totale de
co2 qu'on met dans l'atmosphère c'est ça
qui compte et que cette quantité totale
soit émise par un milliard ou 10
milliards d'hommes sache ça change pas
le problème ce qui compte c'est la
quantité totale
donc il ya un gâteau donné à se partager
et plus on est nombreux à se partager
plus chacun devra faire d'effort donc là
vous touchez du doigt quelque chose qui
est absolument cruciale c'est qu'on a un
sujet démographique qui pour le moment
est un des non dits dans ce débat 1 est
ce qu'on accepte d'en parler d'eux
serait ce que t'en parler des jardins et
j'insiste 1 c'est vraiment un sujet qui
prend aux tripes pas la question mais
qui est un des sujets difficiles dans
cette histoire parce que c'est évident
que plus on est nombreux et plus chacun
doit faire des efforts ou al'inverse
plus on est nombreux et en fonction de
l'aptitude qu'on a vraiment faire des
efforts plus on est entre guillemets mal
parti là dessus et sur un certain nombre
d'autres sujets voilà donc c'est un des
éléments centraux du débat aujourd'hui
très difficile à évoquer de manière j'ai
envie dire un peu calme mais c'est un
c'est un truc absolument centrale et
bien mesdames messieurs je vous remercie
il est 7 heures peut-être
mais je propose qu'on arrête là c'est à
la fois un exercice extrêmement
important qu'on vient de faire là
évidemment assez frustrant parce qu'on
n'a pas pu traiter toutes les questions
on va trouver le moyen de les traiter
merci à vous quatre d'être de vous êtes
prêté à cet exercice auquel je pense que
vous n'êtes pas complètement habitués
mais justement c'est on va se petit à
petit s'habituer la diffusion s'arrête
maintenant